and thank each and every one of you for
being here I think I'm doing this right
okay that's kind of close enough okay
we asked a couple of questions so I know
who I'm speaking to how many of you are
already using youngevity products raise
your hand okay 90% of you all right how
many have heard me lecture live before
okay good half and so I do have to go a
little slowly well for those of you
haven't heard me speak live before well
how many of you hear me on the radio how
many ever listened to me on the radio
okay good the other half is good the
thing that makes my view different on
health is that I have a degree in
agriculture from University of Missouri
I'm a veterinarian from the University
of Missouri and I wrote the first paper
on a mass die-off in America from
pollution has never been written up
before here in America and I was lucky
enough to run into that event and I got
written up and that would direct the
rest of my scientific life that was in
1962 became a compare two pathologists
as Ted alluded to and that worked with
Marlin Perkins me old Mitchell Omaha
Wild Kingdom show some year old enough
remember that he was before the
Crocodile Hunter for younger ones
okay and the thing that I was able to do
in that project with Washington
University in st. Louis was to do these
autopsies on both humans and animals and
one project and one project over 20,000
autopsies went over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 humans for comparison
there's over 10 million chemistry's and
that many slides with special stains in
the book that came out of its 1,200
pages and it's in the Smithsonian
Institute is a national treasure
they will ply never be repeated because
the expense today would be over a
billion dollars for that project well
make a long story short became a nature
family physician 1978 and I've been
treating my patients like dogs ever
since they get better the reason why I
say that is in the animal industry we
don't have health insurance there's a
huge advantage
veterinarians not to have health
insurance for animals because we have
health insurance the concern of the
doctor is to get the health insurance
when you don't have health insurance and
let's say it's a cow if you want to
treat that cow for ten years and cows we
don't have insurance let's say a pig if
it has double knee replacement the
farmer doesn't have insurance for a
double knee replacement he has arthritis
in his knees they just eat him
goldfish if it's sick
just flush him down the toilet there's a
flush treatment okay a dog if he has a
2000 dollar treatment most of the time
he's going to heaven the next day at one
o'clock you know the exact moment
because you get the injection right so
in humans we have this problem there's
no law requiring a doctor to cure you
and there's a cure available you assume
because you're innocent that he wants to
cure you you assume because you're
innocent that doctors want to cure you
let's say you have diabetes and I can
cure you in two to 14 days of diabetes
the doctor makes 300 bucks from a office
call actually the pharmacist will make
more money from from the medications
right but if he can treat you for 25
years rather than cure you in three
weeks
he makes $750,000 so it's not unethical
it's not unlawful for him to treat you
for 25 years and so which way is he
gonna go $750,000 over 300 and that's
the problem in human medicine is
insurance is the worst possible thing
that can happen to human medicine
because it made the doctors figure out
how to get the insurance and they treat
you
they ameliorate or dampen down symptoms
they do not cure the disease every drug
with the exception of antibiotics which
can kill let's say have a strep throat
there's an advising cure strep throat if
you have syphilis
penicillin cure syphilis there's always
the infectious disease with an
antibiotic that we can cure there's um
250,000 pharmaceuticals their
prescription drugs and the PDR the
physicians Desk Reference that they have
access to with the exception of
antibiotics which about 500 so two
hundred and forty nine thousand five
hundred our prescription drugs
non-antibiotic only treat symptoms
there's not a single pharmaceutical
other than antibiotic Secours of disease
they all treat symptoms when does the
doctor make the most money when you're
sicker when you're well very sick
when does the pharmaceutical industry
make more money when you're sick and
when you're well now the medical system
has legislated themselves into a
protected monopoly everybody but medical
doctors are quacks everybody knows that
because medical doctors tell you so
they've legislated themselves into a
protected monopoly they have no
oversight by any agency they self police
and they have unlimited money through
government and private insurance BAM
you're dead now I'm going to show you
two things number one I'm going to show
you why you must change what you're
doing I'm gonna show you how to do it
that fair now hold your questions and
comments till the end this is going to
be totally different than any health
lecture you've ever seen or heard
[Applause]
now how many of you guys and gals know
heard of a guy by the name of Benjamin
Rush anybody know who Benjamin Rush was
okay couple of guys in the bed okay
Benjamin Rush was the first military
surgeon in the United States he was one
John's Washington's military surgeon he
was the first US Surgeon General and he
was a signer of the Declaration of
Independence pledging like all of the
other fifty-six his life his fortune and
his his personal good name okay and this
is part of the letter he wrote to
[Music]
Benjamin Franklin and also the other
writers of the Constitution should
cluding Thomas Jefferson unless we put
medical freedom into the Constitution
because the different factions of
medicine were fighting herbalist versus
chemical users and those using oriental
medicine and so forth they were fighting
amongst themselves and so he was
pleading for a clause in the
Constitution that would equal right to
choose religion right to freedom of
speech right he wanted another one in
there unless we put medical freedom into
the Constitution the time will come in
medicine will organize itself into an
undercover dictatorship to restrict the
art of healing to one class of men and
deny equal privileges to others will
constitute the Bastille which is the
most horrible prison in France at the
time of medical science all such laws
are on American and despotic well of
course that didn't happen this clause
didn't get into the Constitution and now
his worst nightmares have come true
three hundred years later now we spend
more money for health care than all the
other nations were all combined there's
200 foreign nations registered in the
United Nations of those 204 nations we
spend more money for health care than
all the rest not more than any nation
more than all nations and what do we get
for it we're ranked 92nd and
healthfulness in the world there was 91
other nations
people's are healthier than us me ranked
60th and longevity there's 59 other
nations whose people's live along us and
God forgive us we're ranked 41st when it
comes to live births and first months
from I've ability babies that doesn't
even count the abortion piece
Time magazine December 2008 cover
article the sorry state of American
health despite technological advances in
medicine Americans are less healthy than
we used to be and the next nation our
kids are gonna be worse off how many of
you have heard that that their kids are
not going to live as long as the adults
okay that's two-thirds of you what
they're saying here is is statistically
three-quarters of you in this room will
be standing at gravesite bearing your
children unless we change what we're
doing petitions are the doctor's
petitions the government aren't going to
change anything that's not going to
change anything there's only one way to
change this system and that is to not
use it cut off their cash flow suddenly
now they become real humble but you have
to make that decision well it takes a
responsibility on your part and I'm here
to teach you the things you can do for
yourself to avoid using them
unnecessarily that makes sense so that's
where we're going just so you don't
think I made that up in ranking of a
newborn deaths
again we're 41st in the world when it
comes to live births and first month
survivability babies and they say it's a
shame it's not a shame it's an absolute
crime and most OBG when most OBGYNs and
most pediatricians should go to jail for
it
[Applause]
I don't know if you've ever heard of the
scientific journal called food chemistry
it looks at the nutritional value of
food growing here in United States and
food import in the United States also
looks for pollution so I'm kind of
familiar with that one and in the April
issue of this year April 2012 there was
a big article in there that looked at
eight very well-known trusted names and
baby foods Gerber's Similac Enfamil
these kind of things and what they said
was that commercially available baby
foods contain less than 20% of the
recommended levels of many vitamins and
minerals and less than 20% this is why
we have autism and ad D and ADHD it has
nothing to do with vaccinations nothing
I've looked at the the batch numbers and
ingredients and manufacturers they send
the same batch numbers at the same
ingredients and all over the world and
95% of all autism occurs here in the
United States so it can't be the
vaccinations because it is used
everywhere else so what is it is
malnutrition to the brain you cannot
make a good brain on Fruity Pebbles and
apple juice most kids who have autism
and ATD in aviation or normal until they
go from formula to solid food what's
their solid food Pop Tarts in Welch's
grape juice you know Sunny Delight and a
goes with syrup all carbohydrates
carbohydrates carbohydrates there's no
fans there's no proteins there's no
vitamins and minerals
and you get what you get you can't make
a brain on carbohydrates only so here's
your pediatrician should go to jail this
is from May of this year cover article
Newsweek magazine in the first reaction
of most people is to have a little
giggle because he's a cute little fat
kid year old he's clutching his
supersize bag of french fries but this
is probably the scariest slide you're
gonna see tonight
because this is one of the reasons why
your kids will not live as long as you
they're predicting already that this kid
here year old when he when I grow up I'm
going to weigh 300 pounds
raise your hand if you know we're the
number one obese nation of the world
anybody know that yeah oh well good
I know it's kind of interesting line
there and those people don't know we're
the number 100 beast nation well the
only thing that we're number one in the
health industry is obesity now what does
that tell you about the medical systems
and the government's knowledge about
obesity they know nothing otherwise we'd
be number 204 we should be the slimmest
trim as good as people on earth but they
know nothing about the thing that makes
us the sickest people on earth
obesity won't talk about that in a
minute a little piece here came out the
19th of September just about a month ago
in 2010 36 percent of Americans are
obese 2032 projecting the 50% will be
obese now what that tells you is they
know nothing because if they knew
something and they could predict what's
going to happen in 20 years they should
say well it's 36 percent now but in 20
years they'll be 20 percent another 20
years would be 5% but instead is going
up which means they have no earthly idea
how to stop it
some states like Mississippi the most
obese nation are excuse me in the state
in America the most obese right now
they're going to be sixty six point
seven percent well 67 percent obesity
two thirds obesity is what they're
projecting for same thing for Maryland
or Gala where I guess as Delaware's
64.7% almost 65 percent and then you're
looking at South Carolina sixty-three
percent this young fella died at 21
years of age of Crohn's disease and a
certain type of liver disease called the
primary scroller sinkhole Anjos which is
a simple nutritional deficiencies how
many ever heard of chromes is 'yes ok
Crohn's disease is a simple problem very
simple problem they say it's an
autoimmune thing he fought valiantly for
11 years and he died all they did was
give him prednisone and cortisone and
tell him to eat you know give up lettuce
and stupid things like that right and he
died at 21 years of age of complications
of Crohn's disease and liver disease all
he had to do was going on a gluten-free
diet we'll talk
that in a minute quite a gluten-free
died taking the 90 essential nutrients
and he'd let it be 121 but when it comes
to these things
doctors are either very stupid are
they're criminals because if they know
the answer and they choose to treat him
rather than cure him they should a cured
him when he's 10 years old then three to
six months but if they're ignorant that
means they don't know what to do if they
know what to do and they choose to treat
him for a long period of time for the
money that means they're criminals right
and so I'll give him the benefit out
just say they're stupid ignorant people
this came out October 11th this is month
stroke rates increase among shown our
patients is happening in younger and
younger and younger people now that are
getting stroke and there's many many
reasons for that but the basic reason is
there's two types of stroke eighty-five
percent of all strokes are caused by
blood clots in the brain thrombotic
stroke this is caused by simple
deficiency the Amega three essential
fatty acids or a ratio plan between
omega-3 sixes and nines now showed pros
to you I actually sued the FDA or this
and prevailed in federal court and I'll
show you what to do to prevent strokes
very simply AARP
their monthly bulletin American
Association of Retired people I'm glad
to see so many young people in here
because we got to start young right we
can't wait till people my doctor says I
have three seconds to live can you save
me with bodies okay you'd be amazed at
how many people I get like that oh I
heard you're taped twenty years ago I
didn't do anything and now I got two
seconds to live can you help me okay so
the AAR people in March of this year the
worst place to be in America when you're
sick is an American hospital I took two
pieces out of the body of the article
and one old which is the number of
American patients who die each year from
American Hospital errors is equal to
four jumbo jets crashing each week
that's about 1,200 to 1,500 people per
week how many of you would fly
commercial airlines if you knew they
killed 1200 1500 passengers every week
nobody would fly
I must see my doctor I must see my
doctor and then also in the same issue
each u.s. surgeon each u.s. surgeon
operates in the wrong person wrong body
part is all in his forty times a week
well that brought sounds to the room
that's because they're usually
intoxicated on alcohol street drugs and
prescription drugs and that comes from a
six year ago study by lucien lepay who's
the head of the department of public
health at Harvard Medical School and he
went around and blindly took blood
samples from doctors he just showed up
and took blood samples from and he ran
him and 52% are intoxicated during their
working day on something that's why they
make so many mistakes it's published
stuff from Harvard Medical School music
magazine cover article why is that guy
terrified
well he's not even anesthetized and
though surgeons are ready to stick him
with their scalpels that's because if
they even touch him with their scalpels
before he undergoes anesthesia they've
started their procedure if he dies
during the induction of anesthesia which
happens quite frequently because they
don't turn on the oxygen and because
they're drunk yeah and he dies let's say
during the induction of anesthesia they
can run off and play golf for four hours
and so get pay they're a hundred
thousand dollars so they want to start
the procedures right now the one word
that will save your life in a hospital
is a two letter word that every
two-year-old knows know whatever they
tell you you're gonna say it respond by
saying no now what is it guy afraid of I
mean this is a universal fear pleasure
right doesn't matter what language you
speak if you're doing this you're afraid
of something no let's say you're in the
hospital you have fourth stage cancer it
has gone to the regional lymph nodes may
be gone from your coal into your lungs
you're in real trouble they said look
we've given you four rounds of
chemotherapy nothing seems to be working
if we have this new experimental drug
coming out in a couple of weeks and we
want to try it on you your response
should be no because they know that it's
not going to work on your 97% of the
time chemotherapy doesn't work for
cancer
that's published in the Journal of
oncology about three years ago ninety
seven percent of time
therapy is useless we gotta give you
something no shrink the tumor a little
bit but you still die okay no so this
experimental drug is gonna be the same
way it's gonna shrink the tumor a little
bit but you still die and so what
they're asking you to do is to let them
use you as a guinea pig to see if just
the injection the drug kills you because
they have to have a hundred patients who
will be injected with a drug and they
have to have less than three died from
the in drug itself before they prove it
so we're looking for the village idiot
okay see if I'm the one you're gonna
kill so what is he afraid of well
there's seven physicians on the other
facing page and once you look at their
body language and their faces to see if
they're coming in to him as good
Samaritans they remind me of the Walking
Dead series on TV the doctors are the
Walking Dead and the reason why they're
coming for him is he is the only one in
the hospital as money everybody else is
a Medicare patient they don't have any
money
they'll play hockey out there they'll
knock each other down because they want
to be the one to get to him to get the
money these are not uncommon things
usually Reader's Digest is a very chummy
magazine was really great stories you
know the dog drags a kid out of the fire
in the house and the two-year-old calls
911 say his grandma from a heart attack
but look at this cover article in 2007
June of 2007 fatal Hospital mistakes how
common is that well in 1999 I made one
of my I don't know 436 CDs I have out
there and I used have to admit I used it
title of a movie how many heard of the
Ray Milland movie some you're old enough
to remember that ol Ray Milland movie
dial M for murder
Balam is a great movie and then it was
remade here about 10 years ago or 15
years ago with Michael Douglas called
the perfect murder the same storyline
just new technology and stuff to make it
modern but it was same storyline all I
did was change it by one letter instead
of saying dial M for murder I sat down
MD from her the doctors didn't like that
they just like went crazy and been in in
this CD in the CD I read this stuff
from this newspaper article each year in
America VA medical doctors make 3,000
mistakes which which cost the patient
there a limb or an eye or to stay in the
hospital for another six months because
of infections or whatever and all those
3,000 mistakes that are inflicted on VA
patients every year by VA doctors the VA
doctors kill 700 veterans that have
scaped death at the hands of the enemy
so they come home to be treated by our
doctors our doctors kill them they come
home to be treated by our doctors VA
hospital and each year the VA doctors
kill 700 of our veterans that went out
there to protect us and the doctors get
a walk they never go to jail because
they have a protected monopoly they can
kill maim rape and and burned with
impunity and they're untouchable this
came out it was a full page story in the
USA Today in February 2007 I had to chop
it up a little bit to get on this eight
and a half by 11 look at that look at
the title here patient protect thy self
now the data that I'm gonna share with
you came from the journal the American
Medical Association very very
well-respected in journal whether you
agree with them or not they are very
well respected and then the Center for
Disease Control which is a federal
agency in Atlanta Georgia that looks at
this stuff and what the article said was
each year in America each year in
America medical doctors kill injured in
fact 15-minute of customers or workplace
they get a walk they don't get an OSHA
ticket each year American medical
doctors kill injured in fact 15 million
of their customers of the workplace 5.8
million in hospitals and 9.2 million in
private office of clinics how many of
you would fly commercial airlines if you
knew that they killed injured infected
15 million passenger
every year nobody would fly this is one
of my favorites each year in America
medical doctors inflict two million
infections on hospital patients all
those two million infections 90,000 die
they kill 90,000 people each year just
from infections if they inflict on the
patient now how could that happen well
that's because they were the same white
coat the same pantyhose the same
trousers the same shoes from room to
room to room
dragging Peapod pus not gunk viruses
bacteria everything you can think of by
contrast in a pig barn by federal law
you're required to disinfect your boots
when you go from one pig pen to the neck
because you want to be dragging swine
flu with you we treat pigs better than
we do people we treat pigs in a barn
than we do people in a hospital now I
want you to think about this if Iran
were to ship over one of their
intercontinental ballistic missiles
which they're always testing with a WMD
weapon of mass destruction there was a
biological weapon a bio weapon which
viruses and bacteria would kill 90,000
people let's say they lob that thing
right into Minneapolis and killed 90,000
people in a couple of weeks or a month
what we do what we do well we declare
war we just go over there and flatten
that country and the rub will kill a lot
of people you know well please say
you're sorry
probably not we sue them and say we we
want some retribution we want a million
dollars per person for every one you
kill probably not we declare war we go
kill them all well here you have doctors
that kill 90,000 every year does
somebody because they don't wash their
hands after they go potty yummy yummy
now how can I say that well this came
out in August but almost exactly two
months ago tomorrow will be two months
ago one bacteria causes 30,000 deaths in
hospitals every year that's one third of
the 90,000 right there's one bacteria
c-diff is Clostridium differential
was only found in human poop say human
poop batteries a human feces bacteria it
comes only from doctors and nurses not
washing their hands patient a patient a
patient to show you how concerned they
are about it doctors in 1993 there were
eighty-five thousand seven hundred cases
of c diff infections in hospitals
reported and by 2010 went up 400% to
three hundred and forty six thousand
eight hundred is he getting better or
worse
well the numbers worked it's getting
worse so when do you say is nothing I
wouldn't get pissed off enough to say
enough is enough
we're not gonna use you guys anymore
once you think remember when that Toyota
there was six six was it sixty people
got killed
sixty people got killed in was four
years or five years from Twyla's
accelerator problem
twelve twelve people a year I mean it
was a big hoo-ha
I mean everybody suing for billions of
dollars front-page stories it was a mess
here we have one trade in their
workplace they killed ninety thousand
from infections over here because they
don't wash their hands after they go
potty
nobody cares that's because they haven't
protected monopolies are you beginning
to get a picture here now there's
another one of my favorites because I
got some very famous examples to show
you hospital care fatal for some
patients well that's kind of you know
vanilla results of Medicare study
alarming well that's alarming
well in the study was done by the US
Department of Health and Human Services
Office of Inspector General Office of
Inspector General that's the auditor for
Medicare
well they said was each month in
American medical doctors kill fifteen
thousand Medicare pay
with non-invasive procedures each month
medical doctors kill 15,000 medication
Medicare patients from non-invasive
procedures how many of you fly
commercial airlines if you know they
killed 15,000 seniors a month especially
be receipt ain't going on that plane man
I'm driving well it's because of famous
people that they've killed for seniors
about a nietzermann anybody remember
Andy Rooney from 60 minutes
Sunday afternoon it's kind of a TV show
well he retired almost exactly a year
going on in October of last year he
retired in 92 years old and he knows why
we're gonna run his world cruise and so
they decided they were gonna go in for a
physical in case they need to take some
medication with him they didn't want to
be out in the ocean for six months and
have to go to some doctor in a foreign
country that they didn't know and all
that kind of stuff and so the doctor for
Andy Rooney he's kind of leafing through
his medical records and he said Andy
you're 92 years old here and I can't
find where you've ever had a colonoscope
exam I mean there could be cancer
lurking around in there and of course he
had no symptoms no bleeding in his bowel
movements no pain no weight-loss he's
happy as a clam waiting to go on as his
cruise and what he should have said was
no but instead what he said was okay
because he didn't want to offend the
doctor in white coat no stethoscope so
the doctors six a garden hose up his
rump puncture his intestine three days
later he's dead from paradise a belly
infection nothing wrong with a guy in
the doctor kills him no they didn't name
the doctor they didn't name the hospital
because if that in the hospital and the
doctor's name went out I mean my god it
would interrupt their cash flow
everybody canceled it would be a mess
right so they're not going to name those
guys know what makes this really bad is
in here the cause of death is listed you
go online and look at Andy Rooney
obituary and you'll find him they always
say mr. Rooney died of complications of
a minor medical procedure but one cut
one minor for him he killed him
doctor gets a walk Hospital gets a walk
honey you heard a dick Clark you know
American Bandstand okay he went in for
an outpatient procedure he was supposed
to be having the procedure 11 done by
11:30 out in the golf course but one
o'clock that's what he was told
now what he was gonna have was one of
those little roto-rooter things that was
prostate gland because he had to stand
for the table for 2 or 3 minutes we're
gonna get a urine stream going so
instead of coming to me and getting it
fixed with nutrition it's a simple
nutritional problem instead of getting a
face with nutrition he opts for the
scientific thing
let's do surgery and row to root it out
starts at 11 o'clock and as a scheduled
11:30 is dead he died of a coronary
thrombosis that happens to 30,000 men
each year within an hour after the
procedure
now there's another 200,000 each year
that have a stroke or coronary
thrombosis but they don't die 30,000 of
them die every year from that procedure
I'll show you that fact in a minute now
how to remember a guy by the name of
Neil anybody remember Neil I'll give you
one more piece of the name how about
Neil Armstrong how do you remember Neil
or I'm from our top astronaut right the
first guy to step foot on the moon he
saved single-handedly he saved two NASA
missions saved the spacecraft saved two
crews it was a mess that he saved NASA
from a terrible disaster two times so
he's eight years old he goes in for his
physical they kneel you're eight years
old we've never seen a specimen like
he's 82 years old you're as fit as can
be that NASA program must be really
great but we did find one little thing
we're concerned about you have a blocked
artery got a 30% blockage in a coronary
artery now it's not dangerous now you
don't even have symptoms no I don't have
any chest pain or anything no angina
okay you're not breath now I said I can
run 20 miles every day no problem okay
well you're fit now and what we're
proposing is we don't wait for five
years until it's 70% blocked or 85% of
blood we don't wait until you have a
heart attack until night
the way the hospital you're fit now no
we want to do is go in there and put a
stent in there do a bypass and you never
had to worry about a heart attack I mean
we're lucky we found it early yes sir
good naval air man let's go for it
where did Neil die from he didn't have a
heart attack he died from complications
resulting from cardiovascular procedures
see the story was not all the wonderful
things as Neil Armstrong did in his life
that was not the story the headline
should have been doctors kill top
astronaut but since they have a
protective monopoly they killed him and
they're hiding you don't know who the
doctor was that killed him
but if there had been a successful thing
that he had this news conference and all
the white coats and stethoscope
oh yeah is a very difficult thing and we
saved the astronaut and how wonderful my
name is doctor so here's my 800 number
you can call me for appointments and it
would be in big hoo-ha right
but since they killed him now he'll let
you know who they are are you beginning
to get a picture here so they can kill
an Andy Rooney a Dick Clark and Neil
Armstrong and another couple of hundred
thousand people each year who are
nameless because they're not famous
Michael Jackson there's another one
stupid dr. Murray probably snorting half
of Michael's drugs
no Michael just happened to pick one of
the dumbest most careless doctors on
earth now honey hurt a cholesterol raise
your hand
you know the substance is cholesterol
okay good now I'm here to tell you this
is not a single disease that's caused by
elevated blood cholesterol there's not a
single disease is caused by elevated
blood cholesterol elevated blood
cholesterol is a red warning light how
do you ever seen the red warning light
in the dashboard of car whether it turns
on or not you know there's a red warning
light right something's going on with
the engine can you name me anything that
that the any mechanical or chemical or
electrical thing that the red warning
light inflicts upon your vehicle no the
red warning light as the name implies it
warns you that something bad is going on
you need to add more coolant you need to
add more oil you may have blown a head
gasket you don't to drive it you want to
get towed in so you get the engine fixed
that's what the red warning light is
warning you right well I made a blood
cholesterol is a warning I wrote that
out in 1971 it was published there's
like translated into six languages a
Danish pathology journal active
pathological and was it was a big thing
and I compared clogged arteries in
vegans versus meat-eaters vegans of
course I think you're all young enough
to know the vegans are people who are
vegetarians who eat nothing but grains
vessels fruits and nuts no animal
products and they believe that's a
healthy thing but I don't believe it's
healthy this is a political statement
because they say okay well one cow eats
as much food as 50 people if we're all
eating stuff like cows and get the cow
out of a cycle we can feed 50 more
people right I mean that's how the
vegans saying well cow has four stomachs
you can't process grass the same way
account us you got fifty thousand little
helpers in there
I mean fifty thousand individual
organism and fifty thousand different
species of individual organs you've got
billions and billions and billions of
little organism there to do things that
you don't have the capacity to do so you
can't live on pasture grass like a cow
so being a vegan is a political
statement rather than a nutritional
statement right so what I did when you
when you do twenty thousand-plus autopsy
and all these different species and
three
humans 10 million slides 10 million
chemistry's you can write a lot of
articles which I did write one of which
was comparing the amount of clogging of
the coronary arteries and vegans versus
meters guessing that the worst clogged
arteries vegans because of poorly stored
grains the oils and the grains oxidize
and turn into trans fatty acids free
radicals which inflame the arteries and
cause them to clog another thing that
happens with vegans they stir-fry
organic vegetables and extra extra extra
extra extra virgin virgin virgin virgin
olive oil turns into trans fatty acids
in flames our arteries and clogs your
arteries somebody lives on you know the
meat and potatoes guy
well he's not burning the meat he's
eaten his meat raw you know or medium or
medium rare and have them some baked
potatoes he won't get clogged arteries
because there's no trans fatty acids any
of that you're getting a picture here so
just because somebody says something's
good when you have to look at it and see
if it really is well again
cholesterol is not bad if you have
elevated blood close from the normal
cholesterol for human beings a normal
range is 220 to 270 222 to 70 is in the
normal range and if you have a blood
cholesterol without medication that's
below 200 you have gluten intolerance
because you can't absorb cholesterol
I've seen people with cholesterol at 60
in their doctor man you you can eat 10
eggs a day and not worry about it
you've got cholesterol 90 a man you're
lucky no no no you're dying because you
have a gluten intolerance you can't
absorb cholesterol which is a very big
complicated molecule okay so FDA has new
safety information to Stanton drugs
cholesterol-lowering drugs February 2012
federal health officials are adding new
safety warnings about the risk of statin
drugs for memory loss Alzheimer disease
and elevated blood sugar if you take
statin drugs lower your cholesterol for
10 years and at the same time you're on
a cholesterol restricted diet you're
going to increase your risk of Alastor
disease by 100% in other words you're
going to get a disease a predictable as
gravity I'll tell you why in a minute
also if you're on statin drugs Lauri
flush when you have a cholesterol
restricted diet for ten years increase
your risk of type 2 diabetes by 50%
what causes elevated blood closer to
glycerides is is a red warning light for
diabetes it's a red warning light for
low thyroid it's a red warning light for
deficiencies of six different minerals
in itself causes nothing I said that in
1971 everybody I shouldn't say everybody
there's 25 doctors I used to hang around
with and of course they just put their
arms around said a wallet can mean you
know you must be sniffin glue everybody
knows it's that it's the cholesterol man
well they all took their standard drugs
and guess what
they're all dead I'm alive
god is good okay science news is kind of
a a summary journal for doctors they
they look at thousands of scientific
articles written every month and they
summarize them so doctors can read the
summaries which usually are a half a
page and they like something they can
send somebody to get the entire article
they don't to read thousands of articles
this came out in June of this year good
cholesterol not so beneficial high
higher HDL and hideout high density
lipoprotein the good cholesterol don't
reduce heart attacks I said that 1971
everybody laughed at me as published go
back and read it okay and so it's nice
to be redeemed a little bit right I'm
gonna go to each of their graves and put
one of these on their hood okay now
there's not a single medical screening
test that prevents a disease and I saw
on TV the other night when the American
Cancer Society still talking about get
your screens to prevent cancer there's
not a single screening test medical
screening test prevents of disease now
it might catch it earlier we can get
into the treatment system which can be a
bad or good thing right
so this is the globin male which is the
USA Today equivalent in Canada it's a
national newspaper I just like this
title along with that picture here
screening is not prevention now how many
of you ladies have heard of mammograms
raise your hand if you don't raise your
hand you're probably lying we hated men
of hurry mammograms right and that's one
of the great screens that doctors like
to use ovg wins your primary care
physician will send you in for a
mammogram every year once for 40 years
of age well you know women I don't know
10 15 20 years ago when these things
were really being pushed they said what
about all that radiation don't you know
I'm trying to stay away from radiation
I'm protesting against nuclear power
plants want me to put my breast in that
machine or it's insignificant radiation
how many women have heard that yeah well
I just came out about three weeks ago
they said one mam again one mammogram
gives you the Monterey
500 chest x-rays Wow sorry little
mistake was a decimal point problem one
mammogram one cat scan one MRI gives you
the equivalent radiation 500 chest
x-rays if you have one mammogram ladies
a year for five years increase your risk
of breast cancer by 20% and if you're
taking HRT if you're taking you know
estrogen along with that oh you're up to
60% increase in risk of breast cancer if
you're if you're eating your meat cooked
well done at the same time it increases
your risk of breast cancer by 462
percent I'll actually show you that that
experiment experiment is done there's a
20-year study on the Nurses Health Study
by the University of South Carolina on
90,000 nurses over 20 years increases
your risk of breast cancer by 462
percent now to see Susan G Komen tell
you that so next time your doctor says
look it's time for you I looking in here
you're beyond your year you need to go
get a mammogram you should say well I
don't think I want to do I'm concerned
about the safety and the doctors say
well I insist because I mean come one
responsible for your health I don't want
you get breast cancer now what he's
really saying is I don't want to give up
my $400 I get kicked back from the
radiology laboratory because radiology
is one of the things that doctors get
kickbacks on if you get an ultrasound
they get 10 bucks a mammogram 400 bucks
they're happy about those things right
now
so what you're gonna say ladies is this
look I'm concerned about safety if you
can convince me to say if I'll do the
mammogram and here's what I want you to
do
why don't you do is put your testicles
in the machine
and I want you to let me be the one to
crank down on that plate until you've
grown a little bit then I want to be the
one to yell to the guy standing behind
the 2 inches of lead and say hit it
Frank if you'll let me do those three
things
I'll get the mammogram hey you know what
that doctors gonna say no you can do
your own self-examination 10 o'clock in
the morning on the 15th of every month
you hear 10 years into menopause and
keep a log and map out your breasts for
all the little bumps and lumps or you've
had all your life you know what kind of
thing and but suddenly now this little
pea-sized knot that's been there forever
is a little tender now it never used to
be tender go get a high definition
ultrasound will actually give you more
information in a mammogram there's no
radiation now you guys don't get off
easy
a federal panel now is discouraging PSA
prostate screening why PSA risk might
not be worth and this is where that
30,000 number came from how do men fare
after the surgery oops houston we have a
problem
Time magazine health and science section
June 4th 2012 skipped the PSA screen
experts say PSA blood test for prostate
cancer don't save lives now and Warren
Buffett was diagnosed with prostate
cancer in April of this year he chose
aggressive treatment surgery radiation
chemotherapy has anybody seen or heard
of him in the last 6 months
is he dead in the freezer waiting for
the stock market to go right before they
reveal his death
I mean is he offered covering in some
island someplace so he's in a coma is he
in Hospice I mean they don't have any we
don't know what's going on right wait
this is his story but the most important
piece of the story when this is written
up was this paragraph here Richard Adlon
the scientist who discovered the PSA
test calls the testings widespread use a
public health disaster because it gives
a 98% false positive
gives a doctor's permission to kill you
prostate cancer does not kill anybody if
you have prostate cancer you die it's
always from the treatment it never goes
to your liver your lungs your brain you
never kills you it goes regionally it'll
go into your pelvic bones here and
lumbar vertebrae in your leg bones but
that's it probably 90% of all men who
die over the age 85 have prostate
cancers usually the size of the head of
a pin
never left the prostate gland but the
PSA test is like 100 instead of below
five like it's supposed to be oh my god
oh oh oh you got to get treatment here
hmm you're dead now doctors have become
pre grave robbers they got a couple more
of these then you'll understand where
doctors are coming from then I'll tell
you what to do for our okay I got a few
more to show you
Cole more categories here Medicare costs
for hospice is up 70% every year 70% 70%
70% how much does it cost to stick your
finger and somebody's trying to already
see if they're dead
need a lot of technology there right and
so why would hospice care well here's
why doctors become pre grave robbers
let's here in a hospice let's say his
grandma Daisy
grandma Daisy's in the hospice and she's
got Stage four colon cancers gone to her
brain she's in a coma she being fed IV
and the doctor calls for conference the
immediate family there at the hospice
and they're all there tears coming down
looking at Grandma Daisy there she's
kind of gonzo she's in a coma because of
those cancers going from her colon her
brain the doctor saying look we can pull
the plug she'll be dead in three days
but I recommend we kind of do what we
can to keep her going here I want you to
sign a paper allowing us to resuscitate
her if she has cardiac arrest because
there's this new drug coming along and
it might just help her of course the
instinct is a wonder grasp onto that
last straw right yeah well let's go for
it yeah we got insurance you'll pay for
it and so everybody especially as you
and variably it's the biggest guy in the
family you know the grandson who's seven
foot tall tied in you know weighs 300
pounds
can kill you with a look right and he
looks at the doctrine says whatever
grandma Daisy needs she gets right oh
yes sir gram Oh Daisy was a she ironed
our underwear she made all our food from
scratch nothing ever canned or frozen
she was the best
whatever grandma Daisy needs she gets
and as he's walking out the door
whatever grandma do don't forget she is
the best oh yes sir well as soon as
everybody signs a paper and they've left
the room
this doctor this hospice doctors on the
internet : all his golf buddies
I checked out grandma Daisy here and
she's got 300 thousand dollars left in
all her accounts between Medicare or
private insurance and everything and her
supplements got 300 thousand dollars
they're there in a heartbeat to give her
a hysterectomy double mastectomy they'll
do a double hip replacement double knee
replacement cataract surgeries if she
has one tooth they'll yank that doing
upper and lower dentures and then they
put implants in her middle ear because
she was deaf and then they pulled up
Lexi Cohen when they call them scrambled
Daisy had a turn for the worse and she
died but only after they get the money
so what I want you to do is have a
hospice at home Medicare will pay for a
hospice at home everybody comes in and
needs to come there and do it I wasn't
necessary give her a better thing but
you have some control here if you let
her I have her dog in her bed with her
you let the grandkids sleep with her if
they want she can have a gallon of ice
cream every night if she wants
you can't give grandma Daisy ice cream
in a hospice she's dying you can't let
the grandkids come if she's in intensive
care you can't let grandkids come in to
give grandma Daisy a hug do you see the
difference here why do you want the
people you love dying by themselves well
the nurses are all chasing the doctors
around in the library at night
after all this for the plush chairs
alright just you know that I'm not
making this stuff up
doctor repeat surgery program gives up
license now this guy did he had ten
times the number of repeat surgeries on
people than any other doctor in the
state of Oregon and it was only because
he had 40 lawsuits against him that the
that the organization did something
about it this came out in September 7th
of this year
here's healthcare waste 750 billion oh
that's 3/4 of a trillion dollars that's
three quarters of a trillion trillion
dollars every year the medical system
wastes three quarters of a trillion
dollars a year that's your tax money now
what was it waste far unneeded care in
hospice I never say anything I can't
back up this is gonna make you feel warm
and fuzzy each of you owes the Chinese
government five hundred and thirty four
thousand dollars
which total of seven is 62 trillion now
why is that that's because over the last
30 years each one of your elected
officials in Washington regardless of
party independence libertarians
Democrats Republicans they all did it
what they did was they took all your
money from your Social Security Fund
your Medicare your Medicaid funds and
gave it over to the highway departments
what you see all this highway work going
on here is that Social Security money
that's your Social Security money okay
and and this was so they could come back
and say I brought home the bacon last
year I got a hundred new jobs in this
district and I want you to reelect me oh
yeah well when the first when the first
baby boomers came along 80 million I'm
the first wave about four years ago came
along okay we're here for our so sturdy
everybody's looking each other in
Washington so well you got to wait six
months thanks you're gonna wait another
six months and so now I think you got to
be 70 before you get your first payment
Social Security used to be 65 right got
to keep waiting and waiting and waiting
that's why because there's no money
there so they run to the Chinese we need
money okay we'll give you the sixty two
trillion dollars and want some security
here so what security did they have to
give for sixty two trillion dollars it
wasn't a signature in their name what it
was was all the weekly revenues from
federal lands oil leases we're talking
about timber permits grazing permits all
of the tolls from the federal toll roads
weekly bypasses all the American banks
and go straight to China not even
keeping up with the interest because
this is a year old is now seventy
trillion this is outside that sixteen
trillion that's you know we're behind on
our budget this year we're behind in her
budget sixteen trillion that doesn't
count this
I knew that would make you feel warm and
fuzzy now doctors are always at the
bottom of it this came out in 1997 a
1997 study by the Health Insurance
Association American found the 75% of
insurance fraud which is a federal crime
is committed by providers which is a
code word for doctors you do that you go
to jail doctors know that they get a
walk now you do have to change your diet
now we're changing subjects a little bit
here you have to change your diet party
responsibilities there's 20 of these
billboards around the Beltway around
Chicago see Wyant earth was they - they
had that's because 75 years ago the
average age of diagnosis of colon cancer
was 61 now it's 38 as this billboard is
directed to eight-year-olds now you talk
to a an 8 year old about grandma Daisy
dying of colon cancer well she was 82
years old I'm only 8 that's a million
years from now I'm not worried about
colon cancer and so this is directed an
eight-year-old a what momma what's
what's but cancer well when I was a kid
38 well no when I was a kid 73 years ago
when I was a kid seventy-three years ago
I had processed meats with nitrates in
it once a year that was ham on Easterns
now kids have processed meats with
nitrates into 15 times a day they get
bacon and eggs I get ham and eggs they
get sausage and eggs they get the all
meat breakfast with 14 different types
of sausages and bacon and ham and
pastrami and pepperoni and jerky and
then they get the bacon bits in their
salads they have bacon burgers and
theirs in their little Lunchables or
these little rods made from pepperoni
you know they're getting all this
nitrates and nitrates and then there's
fried foods you got to give up fried
foods this guy's been dead for 35 years
he's still killing people
now you can eat safely at these places
you can eat stable at McDonald's you
need safely at KFC but you got to be
very restricted on what you pick in KFC
you can only eat the Korf see Kentucky
roasted chicken and there's salad bar
that's it nothing else than there is
safe
same with McDonald's when I go to
McDonald and I do that two or three
times a week because I'm on the road I
only eat their angus burgers i get the
swiss mushroom one no mayonnaise no bun
I have mad lettuce pickles tomatoes and
so I'm having a little piece of meat and
I'm having a little salad but no
dressing or anything on it I could do
get their mild salsa try little peg for
the mild salsa on there and then I'll
drink their wild berry smoothies and I
will have their parfaits which is a
little yogurt that has blueberries and
strawberries in it that's the only three
things I'll eat at McDonald's but is
very sad what going to McDonald's as
often as I do I'll always see
grandmothers and grandfathers you know
they're like in their 70s and 80s here's
a little kid in a highchair two three
years old and he's you know a smash and
potatoes and doing the things that
little kids doing high chairs and here's
grandma with the chicken McNuggets and
she's always ripping the skin off the
chicken to make me I could see little
Frankie watch grandma oh goody goody
good for you here honey all these little
skins of the chicken McNuggets so when I
do an autopsy on a kid 12 years old who
dies leukemia I don't put cause of death
as leukemia well you know you have to
have a cause of death I always put
grandma it was crammed all I'm grandma
was the one that gave him permission to
eat the fried foods gave me leukemia now
how many you have a dog anybody in here
have a dog okay good
you haven't eaten them yet
now we've spent a hundred billion
dollars over the last 60 years on dog
food we've done research on dog food for
100 billion dollars over the last six
years what do we get for that well with
triple the lifespan of dogs six years
ago an old dog was eight years old today
old dogs 25 also we've eliminated 900
different diseases and dogs that still
plague humans and all they want all the
dog food industry wants is the next time
you get your next dog you'll use that
same - my god who is really good and you
know a little lucky here lived to be 25
years old and so I'm gonna get that same
dog food so that's why they spent a
hundred billion dollars to make sure you
would continue to use their branded our
food now a couple of questions here they
make dog food for toy dogs under 10
pounds of body weight if you've ever
bought dog for you know this they have
dog food for toy dogs under 20 pounds of
body weight they have dog food for
medium-sized dogs 35 to 50 pounds they
have dog food for large breeds between
50 100 pounds they have dog food were
giant breeds over hundred pounds that's
so every mouthful is perfect dosage wise
by contrast when you look at where
there's nutritional supplements or if
it's cough medicine or prescription
drugs the age is 12 this is for somebody
under age 12 this for somebody'll
rageful oh you know animals are real how
many read those so yeah it's on the
over-the-counter stuff it's everything
well I know a little kids at 12 years
old there are 300 pounds I know eighty
year old people who are 70 pounds so you
can't go by age you got to go by weight
and that's why we're more successful in
Hamlin sir because we go by weight so
here comes the ultimate question there's
two ultimate questions if you were to
ask your veterinarian hey can I get my
dog the table scraps and leftover is
preferentially to dog for me it's cost
me a buck fifty a day to feed this you
know 80 pound dog and my paycheck I cut
in half here and I really want to cut
back and can I get my dog table scraps
and veterinary horrified what we spend a
hundred billion dollars perfecting dog
food eliminate nine hundred diseases and
triple the lifespan of your dog you want
to feed them table scraps
I'm a veterinarian be mortified
no no no no can't do it so here comes
the ultimate question the ultimate
question how come you eat your feed your
kids your grandkids food you know what
kill the dog
you eat you feed your kids create
grandkids food that you know will kill
the dog so we came up with a 90 for life
program and youngevity it's called 90
for life for two reasons number one
there's the 90s evolution 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids 3
essential fatty acids and what it means
for life is for a healthy life it also
means for life for the length of your
life how many years you need to take
oxygen all your life how many years you
need drink water all your life how many
years you need to all 90 essential
nutrients see these are not the optional
nutrients these this is not the wax on
the car these are the things that drive
the engine there's another look at those
90 essential nutrients they're called
essential nutrients ladies and gentlemen
because we cannot manufacture must
consume them every day there's food or
supplements number two if we if we don't
have them you get horrible diseases
which they will all be fatal over some
period of time every one of these you
know calcium deficiency caused 147
different diseases calcium deficiency
alone causes a 147 different diseases
what you think about that why would the
medical profession want you to get all
the calcium you need and there are
people who specialize in calcium
deficiency disease and they make
millions of dollars every year treating
your calcium deficiency with surgery
what's in it for them if they tell you
what to do for your nutrients you can
overdose taking vitamins in middle don't
you dare take them oh my doctor says I
can't take those I can I can overdose
they kill 1.5 million people a year from
pharmaceutical decimal point problems
from pharmaceutical decimal point
problems they kill 1.5 million people a
year but that's ok they're FDA approved
okay we need sixty medals 16 bottom is
12 centimeters three essential fatty
acids and her food plants can take
carbon dioxide out of the air use the
sun's energy process known as
photosynthesis to manufacture long
carbon chains with which the plants make
vitamins amino acids fatty acid for
themselves and those societies that
learn how to eat these plants will get
these things and they live longer and
healthier we need 60 minerals and you
notice the number of minerals is two
thirds and the 90s institutions so
minerals are very important
well plants only need three minerals we
need sixty plants only need magnesium to
make the leaves rain to get energy from
the Sun they also need phosphorus
potassium to drive growth everything
else they need to get from the
atmosphere nitrogen and make amino acids
and protein carbon to make every other
thing they need so if you read a pretty
good slice of organically grown
multigrain bread organic baked by the
pastor's wife in church on Sunday after
his best sermon your fifty-seven show
BAM you're dead but but but he ate so
world is all organic and just baked with
love no nutritional minerals did not
occur to uniform blank around the crust
of the earth they occur in veins like
chocolate and chocolate ice cream which
remember that piece is very important
now how many remember going to mom and
dad's house or somebody or too young for
that you might go to Grandma and
Grandpa's house and remember that they
had a wood stove anybody remember the
wood still of days yeah now what a
grandma and grandpa do with the wood
ashes every morning do they go in the
recycling bin to save the earth and win
the garden exactly right went in the
garden well our wood ash is all the same
no remember the plant only in these
three so that tree might have only been
in a vein that had three minerals
put ahead six eight twelve whatever so
all wood ashes were not alike okay but
they put them in the garden and plan
benefitted any rate what Ash's not
really ashes somebody gave him that name
thousands of years ago and we've kept
that name but they're really the
minerals that the tree sucked up out of
the ground so there's plant minerals aka
wood ashes we throw them out in the
garden the okra and the tomatoes and the
sweet potatoes and the onions and all
the peas and beans and squash and corn
and everything you're growing out in the
garden suck all those minerals up you
eat those plans to get your minerals in
that fashion right that's how the old
people used to get their minerals
through through the you plant minerals
aka wood ash is going to the garden
plant suck them up eat the plants well
at three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882
we know the exact moment 3 o'clock in
the afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
Thomas Edison pulled the switch in the
first commercial electric generating
plant within 10 years everybody in the
city had converted from wood which is
inconvenient and messy for fuel to
electricity propane and natural gas and
here comes the ultimate question here
how many minerals are left over how many
ashes are left four would use
electricity for fuel 0 and what did you
replace that source of nutritional meals
with nothing and that's why we're all
screwed up health-wise
you gave up two-thirds of the nutrients
by changing your source of fuel and
doctors say don't you take vitamins
knows you'll overdose and they're not
FDA approved
this is a cornfield from western
Nebraska once you look at the universe
you know far many of those rows of corn
but look at the uniformity there every
ear every leaf every stalk is exactly
the same same genetic background is a
miracle to behold well I can guarantee a
couple of things just by looking at that
field I know there's at least three
minerals there because you'd have empty
patches there if they were missing any
one of the three magnesium phosphorus
potassium right so you know there's at
least that okay you without a $2,500
analysis of each year corn can you tell
me which road has six minerals which row
has eight minerals which Rome has twelve
which row has 22 you can't tell and so
in the animal industry we don't have
insurance to pay for silly things and so
we just put everything we know that
those animals need in their little
alfalfa pellets yeah we put the corn in
the soy beans a lot of their alfalfa
pellets but we also put 60 ml 16 bottles
full of Centrum acids are essential
fatty acids in there and whatever
nutrition is in the alfalfa is
value-added we don't depend on it but
your die saw that out here in the
auditorium or that gymnasium you know is
the uses I'm sure they use it for lunch
room too it on that far wall there's the
for food plate used to be the seven food
group seven food pyramid for a long time
and the government decided everything
was going bad because nobody could
remember everything on the southern food
pyramid they converted to four and
leveled it out into a plate you're
supposed to eat variety and eat put four
different colors on your food plate
everything to be wonderful that's the
most insane approach to nutrition I've
ever seen somebody needs to go to jail
here they kill more people and all the
terrorists in the world combined every
day now this is a satellite photograph
from a hundred miles up of agricultural
land in Southern California over here is
the Pacific Ocean over here is Yuma
Arizona down here is Mexico up here is
the Salton Sea which gives you some
sense of location there's a salt lake
about 1/10 the size of the Great Salt
Lake in Utah but I want you to
these mineral veins here look at those
veins and minerals every color
represents different minerals different
mixtures and minerals different amounts
of each one and so on how to remember
Popeye Popeye and spinach he's supposed
to get all your iron from spinach
everything well the only place I can
guarantee there's gonna be a lot of iron
is over here because iron in the soil
turns it red I can guarantee just by
looking at this photograph there's a lot
more iron over here in the Rose over
here but am I gonna spend to twenty five
hundred dollars and every kibble and bit
in dog food and every can of dog food
and every alfalfa pellets for a
laboratory I ran the cow to analyze it
make sure it has everything I need no
don't do that what they do is they put
everything they know that animal needs
appropriate for body weight and then
whatever's in the food is just
value-added and if you're expecting iron
in your food on your sweet potatoes your
spinach and you're getting your sweet
potatoes finish over here your s out of
luck okay and so in the animals they get
a better deal because they put
everything in that food now you're
beginning to understand the picture what
about organic I've been saying this
since I did those studies in the 1960s
for the National Institutes of Health or
the big multi-million dollar study I did
this is a meta study with 240 studies
study sees no nutritional edge in
organics now people who grow organics
and people who sell organics will lie to
you there's more nutrition in organic
food that's a lie
you need a non-organic carrot could have
10 times where minerals in it than a
organic carrot depends on what bein in
the field that grew in the only thinking
guarantee from organic is there's no
sprays on it which is not a bad thing
that's a good thing that's a plus no
sprays you know not your chemical load
down that's a good thing but they want
you to also believe that it guarantees
nutrition it does not so people who eat
organic still have to supplement this is
what makes you young Judi unique this is
a compost pile
and this compost pile is made up of
plants or under the sea for thousands
and thousands and thousands of year this
is 25 foot camp of marine limestone it
has um this is a compost pile
this is 3000 foot elevation it goes down
2,000 feet into the ground in this plant
material so we were able to get it
certified organic every year for 35
years has 77 minerals in it including
the 60 essential mineral thank you the
60 essential minerals an optimal amount
nobody else has this so this why we're
so successful there were 900 seasons
that's the miracle stuff there's 25
different ways to get that's the Russian
version okay
no there's 25 different ways to do this
but the most which I say the most easy
for people to understand is the healthy
start pack and this little bottles on
top of here it fits in a kind of
rectangular box this has 245 nutrients
in it which includes 130 vitamins
minerals amino acids and fatty acids
including all 19 own essential ones and
then a bunch of the others that are not
yet considered the essential will be but
it's which I say nobody's motivated to
spend lots of money to prove it because
what are they going to get for it right
and so it's not a commercial thing and
for the most part and
this also has 115 super juices and how
many heard of the super juice like noni
juice goji juice mangosteen acai berry
not Maqui berry you know from Bolivia
and so on
well I'm Patagonia that's another place
they come from Harry this is great stuff
has 245 nutrients learning all 90
essential nutrients and optimal amounts
and this is this is one healthy start
pack is designed for 100 pounds of human
flesh for a month
so you give that one pack to a 50 pound
kid that's for two months give to
somebody who's 90 110 pounds that's for
one month you get to a 200 pound person
that's for two weeks because by body
weight that way we're more
terrific right so we do everything in
youngevity bye-bye because I'm a
veterinarian and a physician so I try to
get as much as I can the good stuff from
the veterinary industry and bring it
over to people that's why I say I treat
you like a dog would you get better and
this is it this is that chart just on
the wall over there I looked at that man
that's you're just supposed to eat fruit
and vegetables and grains and protein
and everything's would be fine that's
why America is sick that's why all the
jobs were shipped out of America all the
assembly jobs all the the manufacturing
jobs are shipped out of America because
the high cost of medical benefits for
employees now how many how many old
enough remember the 1962 presidential
election you better remember that in
here sir four people are old enough okay
here well there was a three-way race
between old Bush 41 Ross Perot and Billy
Clinton hmm the three rivers the only
thing I can remember from that campaign
were they all 43 were running and they
there were only different by like three
points Billy Clinton won the presidency
with 32 percent of the vote now in
Europe in England they would've had a
runoff between the top two guys would
have been a runoff between Billy Clinton
old Bush the Ross Perot had just about
as many votes as everybody else it was
very close kind of interesting race the
only thing I remember from the campaign
was Ross Perot was the biggest cartoon
character because his huge years in a
Texas accent only showed was a Texas hat
and ears sticking out of it no that was
Ross Perot his picture right great
cartoon stuff but hearing what he said
was if anybody signs NAFTA here this
giant sucking sound as all the jobs
leave America remember that Ted yeah
everybody said that guy's an idiot what
do mean all those jobs really America
were they gone well as soon as Billy
Clinton signed NAFTA like in his first
week of his president temple he signed
in doesn't be the greatest thing he gave
permission for all the publicly traded
corporations to leave the country and
take the jobs with him they started
building infrastructures in these
foreign countries so the infrastructure
to build all the jobs started going away
that's because they don't have
the need nor the requirement for health
care benefits in those foreign countries
now what does a publicly traded company
built for four who profit for who the
shareholders the owner of the company is
there any law moral or our legislative
law requiring a publicly traded company
to hire an employee no such law so they
took all the manufacturing jobs outside
of this country because nobody else has
requirements for health benefits
Southern America and doctors are
protected monopoly they just raise the
price room oh we got more we need more
money I mean the medical costs are going
up we need more money medical costs are
going up because you can't go to a
second person you can't go get a
competing bid for a roof you got a three
or four or five or six different people
you can you know compare quality with
money you can't do that with a doctor
because every doctor's gonna say the
same thing the only difference between
the doctors is one may kill more than
another that's it there's no requirement
for them to post that you can't tell by
looking at them Isis looking guy that's
the one that kills the most so this is
that for food root plate grilled chicken
breast seam vegetables some berries here
with some auric points a lot of great
organic rice and millet I guarantee you
couple of things about looking at that
plate number one there's four minerals
and I can guarantee for minerals or some
sulfur in the chicken breast because
it's required for the essential amino
acids it has to have some sulfur Metheny
and cysteine cysteine I can also
guarantee there's some magnesium there
because that's what makes that broccoli
great right everything else all the
other plant materials have magnesium
phosphorus potassium they might not have
any minute magnesium in here the only
manganese in that plant may have only
been in the leaves so but there's some
magnesium here so there's four minerals
sulfur magnesium phosphorus that's all I
can guarantee there's some beta carotene
and the carrots there's some work points
antioxidants in the berries there may be
some Listeria and the cantaloupe
killya and so the only way to guarantee
you're gonna get all 90 essential
nutrients is to supplement you
supplement again your vegetables your
proteins your fats which they didn't put
in the other side they said
carbohydrates or they said drains wood
they said was grains but they left out
the FAFSA piece so I had the fast you'll
see in a moment why and then fruits
embarrassin but the only way to
guarantee you're gonna get everything
you need there is the 99 16 minerals 16
by 12 cents meadow history such fatty
acids you must supplement every day like
we do for dogs and cats and chickens and
turkeys and ducks and sheep and pigs and
horses and so on
now how many you're born between 1946
and 1964 raise your hand okay good
that's half the people in the room okay
your baby boomers and your you have a
problem you listen to doctors because
doctors convinced you if you listen to
them you'd be the first generation where
everybody lived to be a hundred houston
we have a problem because everything
that doctors told you about health is
wrong everything they told you is wrong
because it's designed to direct you
towards treatment programs as opposed to
cures and Prevention's so about three
years ago my wife and i came up with our
most recent book we got a couple more in
the pipeline here coming out for next
year but three years ago he came out
with immortality and we looked at the
top 20 longevity cultures on earth that
were written up by the National
Geographic we were 60 years worth of
national Geographics looking for this
stuff right we did this in a 10-year
period and we went to four of these
cultures and countries we went to the
internet and books and reference
materials for the others and what we did
was look at the agricultural departments
the anthropology departments and looked
at everything the ate how many calories
they took in their average lifespan all
that kind of stuff right now it's
interesting to me that of the top 20
longevity cultures in a single first
world country or industrialized nation
all the top 20 longevity cultures are
third world cultures are illiterate no
doctors no hospitals no clinics no
pharmacies no primary
our government insurance I mean if you
were to put put a piece of paper all in
a dead gymnasium out there with all the
assets of each country without the name
of the country you would not go to the
top 20 longevity cultures on earth
because they don't have anything do you
think it was being important for health
no doctors an ambulance service no 9-1-1
I mean come on
and those no pharmaceuticals no hospital
no clinics they have no they have no
utilities that should begin to ring a
bell then no utilities and their their
common fuel is wood and by dumb luck by
dumb luck all the trees they use for
fuel grow in a place it has all 60
essential minerals and they put those
plant minerals aka wood ashes all 60
essential metals in our Gardens that are
open or Pease and there's sweet potatoes
and they eat them and they get all the
nutrients you see it's not technology
your good genes that make them live the
long this is they're getting the basic
raw materials to maintain themselves and
we give you all this information in this
book I mean this book should be a
revelation to people okay it has 90
essential nutrients and they all come
from different ecosystems islands
mountains deserts tropical forests so we
show you how all these different
cultures get there 90 essential
nutrients they all live on a calorie
restricted diet how many of you ever
heard of the calorie restricted type
thing okay a few of you well there's a
there's a science on calorie restriction
where if you eat a perfect diet
biochemical you have all the vitamins
and minerals and amino acids and fatty
acids an optimal amount for your weight
and you cut your calories in half and
maintain that perfect biochemical piece
it'll double your lifespan there's no
doubt about it now these people are
illiterate they don't have any books you
gave him a book on the calories triggers
that they just look at pretty pictures
there's no pictures in there they use
the book for fuel right they they can't
read and so why would they all be on a
calorie restrictive diet because they're
so poor they can only afford 900
calories a day they're hanging on by
their fingernails but calorie standpoint
yet they work 12 hours a day six days a
week because they have perfect source of
minerals
two-thirds of their essential nutrients
Americans taken 2,800 calories that
thirty two hundred calories three times
with these people take in and our diet
sucks now they don't get any bad things
it's not that they wouldn't eat these
things if they were there if they're
there but by default nobody's going to
build a drive-through for three guys in
a borough there's no cars no roads and
so by a default they're not getting
fried foods and processed meats with
nitrates and nitrites in it and they're
not getting any carbonated drinks okay
and then they do get 20 times and 50
times the antioxidants we do you have 20
times or 50 times and ER so as we do
Americans take in 1500 or AG points o
RACs an acronym or abbreviation for
oxygen radical absorbance capacity which
is measurement of how many free radicals
be neutralized by the antioxidants are
further supplement as the US Department
of Agriculture measurement and what
they're doing is tracking if they test
how many ort point should take in they
say okay people are taking in a hundred
thousand all right points every day
don't get cancer that's what they're
looking for some number like that right
that's why they're doing it well
Americans taken fifteen hundred or
points a day 1500 and these third world
cultures take in 20,000 50,000 a day
okay they're getting like 15 to 20 times
when we take in or more maybe 40 times
so in some cases so these are things
that we felt were important okay now if
you just take the antioxidant piece has
120 v to the of the recipe and you'll
still diet 68 to 72 just taking a super
juice it will make you live 30 seconds
longer you need the other 24 pieces of
the recipe to particularly the
two-thirds which are the minerals right
let's look at billionaires billionaires
are billionaires because they have a net
worth of at least 1 billion dollars now
Forbes magazine looked at them and I've
been after him for like 10 years there
any Studies on what kills billionaires
no no no no for years years finally in
2004 they came out of the study so I
take a little bit of credit for
judging him for 10 years to do that what
kills billionaires they say billionaires
are killed by the same unglamorous
things to kill everybody else stroke
heart attacks diabetes obesity cancer
kidney failure suicide all the stuff
that kills everybody else kills
billionaires right the average lifespan
of billionaires by 2004 was 78 the
average lifespan of a falling-down red
wine drunk in Minneapolis 275 you don't
gain a whole lot in longevity by being a
billionaire and then I want you to think
about it there's not as of 2004 there
had never been a billionaire it let it
be 100 now think about it how have you
ever seen these newspaper reports
birthdays or death certificates or
deaths the people were 110 hundred so
any kind of thing has anybody ever seen
a white Harvard doctor let it be 100 and
know they're always a little black lady
in East Texas in panhandle of Florida
and Louisiana Western West Virginia in
the mountains someplace in the swamps of
Louisiana because they have no utilities
and my dumb luck
the trees are using for fuel and the 60
essential minerals in it and all the
people with high technology died younger
well they didn't like that so they made
him redo it and in March of 2011 they
redid it for his magazine redid it in
March of 2011 and they said there's
still not been a billionaire allude to
be 100 but the average lifespan did
change it went from 78 in 2004 to 66 and
2011 they lost 12 years of average
lifespan following the doctor's
instructions now the peak of American
longevity occurred 20 years ago has been
dropping at an ever-accelerating rate
since then women used to live 10 years
longer than men
now it's only three years longer than
that we're taking within another ten
years women and men will die the same
age on the average now what's going on
here
that's because baby boomers have
depended on technology and they weren't
getting the nutrition and it's starting
to show up now here's a guy intelligent
as you can get
iPod iPad iPhone this guy was a genius
and Mark and he was a genius electronics
and computers I mean that you got to
give this guy credit when it came to
healthy that he was an idiot he dies at
fifty six ten years before the average
lifespan they're a billionaire so what
happened here well when you're a
billionaire you can afford the best
personal trainer the best food the best
chef cooks the way the doctor wants them
to cook you get all the organics you
want I mean you can get the best health
care plans you can find the most
expensive maybe not the best doctors
it's certainly the most expensive
doctors if there's a health thing you
need someplace you can send your plane
and your pilot to go get it you can tell
them take you someplace if you take out
the billionaire's by themselves look at
them as a separate demographic they
should be the healthiest and longer
people in America shouldn't they be
money meant anything for health don't
you think yeah okay so why is it heat
down at 56 because he he was at veggies
you know he was a vegan how many knew he
was a vegan he was a vegan you know none
supplemented vegan didn't supplement
because he got the very best organic
food here's the vegan unsub lamented
vegan because he got the very best and
his chef made him the very best organic
vegetables stir-fried an extra extra
extra extra extra virgin virgin virgin
virgin olive oil and as a result from
all the free radicals he got pancreatic
cancer now here came the juncture in the
road he should have gone to the Nicoya
Peninsula in Costa Rica and Central
America because that's where the longest
lived people on earth live the people
who lived the longest on earth live in
the Nicoya Peninsula on the Pacific
coast of Costa Rica there's no doubt
about they outlive everybody about ten
years so he should have gone there and
found the oldest of old person you know
great great great great great great
and said great-great great-great
great-great grandma when she feed me
like you've been eating now won't you
give me the herbs you would give
somebody with really advanced cancer and
he'd still be alive today if he did but
instead he went to the most decorated
the most heralded research cancer dr.
Pam he was dead
they sure as they shot him in the head
they killed him and now you know his
Paul Hardy would say the rest of the
story now how do you think that exercise
is good for I raise your hand what do
you believe it or not how many of you
heard that exercise okay let me rephrase
it okay I think everybody's heard that
exercise is good forever well exercise
one of the most dangerous enterprises
you can be involved in exercise kills
more Americans than terrorist when you
exercise you sweat don't you when you
exercise you sweat when you do physical
work you're throwing bales of hay you're
on a roof roofing your carpenter your
plumber you're working at a steel mill
and all the blast furnace and heat
you're sweating right and people who
love you want to take care of you see
they know you're sweating then you're
exercising or you know even a peewee
league you know or Pop Warner leagues
these little bitty kids out there
exercising
men-women doesn't matter gender age you
see look honey I want you to take plenty
of what Walter so you can re hydrate and
that's what kills you this is what
kaljaa because sweat is not water sweat
is a soup that contains all the
nutrients floating around your blood so
you're sweating out this soup you're
placing in the water now that's kind of
like your car's leaking a quart of oil
every week see I'm not going to spend
the dollar 99 little clunker so you put
a quarter water in there what's gonna
hit by the third or fourth week your
engine is a big ball of flame and burn
it up I mean even a idiot living under
the bridge who's gonna steal your cars
gonna check the oil before he steals it
right why would you risk his freedom
from taking a car with no oil in it okay
so
is problematic as a result as a result
when you take all professional athletes
together all sports there is life span
of 62
you take football players only this just
came out two years ago I actually have
the papers if you want me to prove it if
their average life span professional
football player is 51 and with the
exception three black guys from the old
Negro baseball league days back in the
1920s there's never been a professional
athlete ever live to be 100 there's
never been a billionaire Lee to be 100
so I'll use all the things that you
think of as being important for health
and longevity aren't real I speak for
hours on on athletics I deal with
professional teams and Olympic teams and
so on let me just show you this you've
all heard ACL injuries and cartilage
injuries and tendon injuries and muscle
things these guys get ten million
dollars a game this is what happens so I
mean I'm supposed to be the fit of the
fittest there drinking water or Gatorade
if they're drinking Gatorade or eighty
eight charge for making water than 100
shark not you sure I want you look at my
left hand my left hand is the
nutritional reserves in the body and
here you are you're sweating and working
out whatever you're doing you're
sweating and you're drinking water
what's happening is your nutritional
reserves they're going down if you're
replacing soup with water right you
reach a point which your tendons can't
maintain themselves they break down you
go a little farther you're Carlos starts
shredding go a little farther you get
diabetes and heart disease a little
farther BAM you're dead and now again
you know the rest of the story my level
are we sell water but I put a lot of
things in it
here's a guy wanted to be a professional
quarterback had three ACL injuries in
his knee
how many knees is a guy have Elizabeth
Taylor had seven hip replacements how
many hips did Elizabeth Taylor have you
see there's no a lot requiring a doctor
to cure you there's always really except
treatment you have good insurance well
insurance pay for it go ahead doc so
make a long story short because of all
the athletes we work because we came out
with a oh I should tell you one other
piece and that is each year according to
the Center for Disease Control seventy
five thousand one hundred thousand young
people in America 75 thousand one
hundred thousand young people in America
die each year while they're exercising
under age of thirty now wait a minute or
do that the doctors told you exercise is
good for you
don't take any vitamins minerals drink
plenty of water mmm and so we came up
with a sports drink called rebound it
has a hundred nutrients so if you have
somebody you love who's sweating in
their labor or their because they play
sports you need to get them on the
rebound it has a hundred nutrients in it
there's a good doctors yes news report
February 5th
excuse me February 2005 US News will
report rated America's most credible
print news source special health issue
who needs doctors your future position
might not be a medical doctor may be
better off now do you think that every
MD in Apple Valley made sure this was in
their waiting room and that came out and
I don't think so I think probably they
sent out the Boy Scout Troop there the
David hem will give you a thousand bucks
just go collect all those magazines out
of every store and shred them by a lot
of tents now why did they do that well
they did that because they backed a the
doctors against the HMOs in the 1990s
how many remember that great battle
between the HMOs and the doctors the
doctor said where the doctor here we're
supposed to be the ones to decide what
treatment you get why would you want an
account in an HMO decide and what
treatment you
that's because the counting of the HMO
knew of the HMO can only be profited
profitable if they cured you they were
going for the Cure and the doctors
wanted to treat you for 25 years and
everybody went with a doctor everybody
was a doctor you've been better off
along with the HMOs cuz they wanted to
cure you doctor didn't like that well my
original audio cassette tape April of
1993 I said it was a study based on a
database of 200 doctors I just grabbed a
handful of general American Medical
Association on the medical library ended
up the age of death of 200 doctors
divided by 200 I got 58 and why would
you want to go to in the seat on your
case I'd say no why would you want to go
to a group of people whose average
lifespan is 58 to learn how to live
beyond an elf away didn't make sense to
me well they didn't like that so they
did their own study and they said
Wallach lied there his life span apropos
of a family doctor or primary care
physician is not 58 like wallet claims
is 56
now some people get the math pretty
quick here
I said 58 they said 56 there was so
eager to show that my statistics were
wrong that they failed to appreciate
that they're telling people that they
died two years earlier than I said so I
do apologize for giving him two too many
years so the information is still the
same why would you go to a group of
people whose average lifespan is 56 to
learn how there'd be 100 this fella here
Socrates a great international soccer
player is also a cardiologist who the
filling of his cardiologist my wife
loved this guy just cause he's
good-looking young men my wife 70 years
old she said I'm a cougar so she thought
this cute guy you know just so cute
that's about honey he's dead
because he only drank water let me show
you my favorite obituary my favorite
obituary is George Francis died 112 he's
the oldest man in America in December of
2008 he's an elite black fella from the
swamps Louisiana so you already know
where I'm going never went to
kindergarten
as his daughter reading the newspaper
him couldn't read never had a job
we got a paycheck with deductions in it
and so he he never had any Social
Security never had any Medicare Medicaid
never went to a doctor using grandma's
herbs use wood for fuel and still drank
a lot of white lightning rolled his own
cigarettes that kind of stuff
a crawdads and you know fried catfish
and sweet potatoes and onions ain't
peppers like the Creoles and he dies 112
is the oldest man in America mm-hmm no
these guys who did this obituaries a
said he lived through 19 US presidents
whose average life span 275 average life
span the US president 75 when you take
out Jack Kennedy assassinated
40-something right and they have at
least one University Green let's roll or
they have to they're cared for by
medical doctors have at least one unit
well they actually have two universities
an undergraduate degree in a medical
degree and then if they're a specialist
like me they had three 4° okay and the
average lifespan of medical doctors by
their own statistics who care for these
presidents of 56 exactly half of
George's age so I wanna know what George
knew right and so when he died these
authors asked his daughter what did your
daddy do two Libyan hundred home and she
said he broke all the rules of healthy
eating who came up with rules of healthy
eating medical doctors a little b56
says he broke all the rules that healthy
with a dine heavy on dairy eggs and
large sandwiches nothing but cholesterol
and saturated fat who
[Laughter]
now we laugh at that but there's a
message here there's a message here it's
part of that book in Mart ality when you
see what these people eat you didn't
blow your mind just the obvious what
doctors say is good for you and so why
did he live 112-88 eggs dairy and lard
sandwiches because cholesterol and
saturated fat is not bad remember I told
you everything doctors what about health
is wrong and you're gonna see wait a
minute you're going to be angry angry
angry at the Medical Group okay this gal
here cradle Evans little black lady came
to us and this is Bob and Judy Bell some
of our distributors and Crockett Texas
just outside of in Houston and they
sponsored this gal 15 years ago and she
was 85 years old and though she had like
six disease she had high pressure
diabetes arthritis Mac degeneration she
had a little dementia and we changed her
diet and we got her on the 90 essential
nutrients appropriate to her body weight
and 15 years later until July 8th of
this year she turns a hundred she's a
very large youngevity business she got
over 300 people in her little marketing
group more than pays for her supplements
she has a lot of money left over so she
goes and does all these activities all
over the place and she to me she looks
like she's maybe 75 80 years old she
doesn't look like she's 100 that's her
she doesn't color her hair I just I was
really brilliant we're starting to get
more and more people like her we're
accumulating quite a few people and we
might want to do a story on her about
this okay really super stuff the last
one to show you here before we get the
individual disease I'm gonna go very
fast in the individual diseases got your
pens and paper you'll get most of it
here the last time I'll show you before
I get to the diseases is this one this
is the oldest person we know on earth
now there's probably people who are
older than her but we don't know about
them this gal was born in 1853 in a
little Isle
in Indonesia with no utilities what was
her fuel okay and we know she's born
then because we we can see the birth
certificates and the baptismal records
at the Dutch Reformed Church and a
little island she was born in now in
June of 2010 she's 157 she's still alive
today so she's 159 no doctors on that
island and since this is a fairly
academic group I'm going to throw this
one in here which I don't often but it's
really a great story when Linus Pauling
got his first of two Nobel Prizes the
first Nobel Prize he got was for
studying the nutrition of genes G's
require nutrients to function you take a
gene you throw it in a bucket of saline
water okay gene you're a good gene go
for it make something make a protein
gene just sits there like tar baby gene
can't do nothing without nutrients these
are all mature like a factory right you
need raw material you need energy you
need employees you need parts and all
this stuff
well genes are the same way their genes
are just a blueprint Oh Oh what did the
genome do for us after we spend a
trillion dollars nothing after 20 years
of mapping out the genome they still
haven't cured the cold they haven't
cured anything because genes by
themselves do nothing here acquire 90
essential nutrients - ha ha interesting
this new science is called epigenetics
have you heard of the term epigenetics
okay a few of you good now I've been
involved in this for a long time and
this is where it's at because genes will
not work without nutrition and what he
said when he received his first Nobel
Prize for doing research into the
nutrition of genes and chromosomes and
enzymes he said you can trace every
sickness every disease and every ailment
to a mineral deficiency whoa that's
heavy that is heavy
do you think the medical system liked
him no they actually should have got a
third Nobel Prize because he was the one
that first proposed that the double
helix was how the chromosomes and genes
were laid out he proposed it he figured
it out 20 years before Watson and Crick
got the Nobel Prize fraud and they got
their idea by reading his stuff and he
was cheated he should have shared that
Nobel Prize with them but they took his
passport away from him because the
doctors insisted he was a communist and
he couldn't go to Europe and study the
Alba name of Franklin who was doing all
the x-rays stuff to determine the double
helix and he didn't have email back then
okay now here we go get your pencil
paper out we're gonna run through about
six or eight of the main diseases very
quickly here this is going to be a
revelation for you and I can go fast
because now you know more than doctors
you now become the most dangerous people
in America let's see we have what about
sixty or so people in here and 57 people
signed the Declaration of Independence
and started the revolution against
England change the world those 57 people
really they committed their lives or
fortunes and their sacred honor those 57
people it doesn't take much to win this
battle but we're going to have to be
proactive we can't hope and pray that
the doctors are gonna be the good guys
here we can't have open pray let's see I
can tell by looking at you but just for
just a show of hands how many ladies are
still in the childbearing years okay a
good third of the anyway maybe two
thirds and women here in the room I want
to spend two minutes on birth defects
every birth defects you can name me in
ten times that many you can't are all
caused
nutritional deficiency is the embryo
there's not a single genetic birth
defect we've eliminated all birth
defects in a node by simply giving the
females preconception nutrition perfect
preconception nutrition part of
conception as all we had to do is give
them to good nutrition before they can
see we eliminate all birth defects I've
been doing that humans for 35 years okay
it works like a charm all the disease
you think of her genetic and humans are
not there just deficiencies of the
embryo now why would you know how many
how many different specialties we'd wipe
out if there wasn't another baby born
with a birth defect oh my gosh all these
kids with special needs all these
different agencies raising money to find
research for the Cure we're gonna look
quickly at obesity because we're the
number one obese nation in the world
why are we the number one obese nation
rule because doctors and the government
has no idea what causes it I'm here to
tell you I actually have a book out
there called Hell's Kitchen
the subtitle is the cause prevention
curb obesity nobody else can claim that
they know that because it would be the
number one obese nation of the world
okay so it's not a disease of excess the
reason why we're in such trouble with
obesity is it's not a disease of excess
and that's how the government the
doctors treat is a disease of excess you
need more exercise you need less but
that's not what the problem is it's a
nutritional deficiency disease not a
calorie deficiency but a nutrition
deficiency I'll show you that I'll prove
that to you in a second just show you
that for remembrance right remember that
one now according to experts seventy
percent of our kids under the age of 12
are overweight and forty percent of our
kids on the age of twelve or obese which
is 30 pounds over their ideal weight for
their height and and has nothing to do a
to much screentime lack of exercise or
eating too much has nothing to with any
of that is a simple nutritional
deficiency but you see doctors would
rather give you a bone-marrow transplant
when you have
iron deficiency anemia an iron do you
understand well we've got the technology
we got to use the technology let's do a
lap banding that'll fix it and this is
one of my favorite obesity slides this
looks at obesity in adults in 1980 we
only had 15 percent Americans obese
between 1919 it was like 12 percent 15
percent 12 percent 50 percent
it never really rose about 15 percent
for 80 years boy in here just started
going up like crazy by 2020 years later
it doubled more than double what
happened well right here they took all
the fat out of our diet it's hard to
find fat I mean everything is no fat
low-fat or fat-free we're getting fat
then anybody here but raised livestock
anybody fatten cattle or sheep or pigs
now do you feed them ice cream and lard
and eggs to fatten them up do you feed
them hold reigns to fan him up
classically the answer is yes you feed
him whole grains
99% of farmers feed their cattle and
pigs and sheep and chickens whole brains
to fatten them up
now wait a minute didn't they tell you
to eat whole grains
huh let's have a look at that now see
this is what you're getting probably the
dogs instructions no fat and eaten whole
grains exercising now if the doctors
were correct the chart should look like
that if the government was correct this
chart should look like that but follow
their directions for 20 plus 12 years is
32 years Oh
houston we have a problem here and one
of my favorite obesity slides is that of
Rosalie Bradford she had two Guinness
World Book of Records for obesity number
one she's the heaviest woman ever
officially weighed by the by the
Guinness World Book of Records she
weighed 1,200 42 pounds one thousand two
hundred and forty-two pounds you went on
two dates with Rosalie you had a ton of
fun
do the math
now she also had her second gives rule
book writer she lost the most weight 736
pounds between 1987 1994 this is not
lose 10 Game five of lose ten gained
five our kind of thing this is lose lose
lose lose because they did a lap banding
on her and they put on a 500 calorie
diet and she over those years she lost
736 pounds that's like three people okay
and then she died because fat is not the
problem fat is just a symptom just like
cholesterol is not the problem now what
does it tell you in 1980 was it was 15%
it's almost gone up 300% so what's the
problem here that's because they've told
you to get fat he whole grains exercise
don't take my on his minerals avoid fat
and you get fat I mean if you're not
careful you could wind up and Ruth's
Chris Steakhouse is the meal instead of
instead of eater no end in sight for the
obesity epidemic why is that because
there's 80 million baby boomers come
along we'd hold reigns exercise don't
take vitamins minerals I'm gonna give
you three clues then I'm gonna give you
the answer don't forget the book Hell's
Kitchen this gal here
Natalie Hayhurst from Terre Haute
Indiana was driven to eat light bulbs
now they say it's a rare condition but
it's not a rare condition this happens
with several million times a day in
America she prefers wood paper products
cardboard stick she likes rocks dirt
sheets diet coke can she won't eat
classic coke cans only diet coke cans
she's eating little magnets out of a
shower curtain she loves plastic bottles
and toys I think that's why mcdonnell's
took the toy out of a happy meal so what
what is this condition well you can call
it Piko the munchies you can call it you
know that kind of stuff but but she has
a condition because she's merely
deficient pregnant women get the same
thing weird stuff and women pregnant or
classic reading weird stuff you know
back when your grandmother was out
living
ruler is she had pregnancy she won't
need dirt fortunately there's no
calories in dirt right well ladies heard
your grandma you see dirt when she's
pregnant yeah I mean grandma used to do
that we live in the 17th floor of an
apartment building now in the inner city
where there's no trees even you started
eating the tootsie rolls out of the
kitty litter boxes you're hungry for
weird stuff when you're merrily
deficient you only can't with the kitty
litter box you know what I'm talking
about I want you get the book Hell's
Kitchen because that's going to give you
the details of when and how and gives
you the whole story of the electricity
and how it made us fan Loyola School of
Medicine Chicago oh that's the Russian
version again exercise won't cure
obesity because of your exercise you're
sweating you're replacing your sweat
with water you're sweating out of your
minerals and guess what you get hungrier
if you're skinny you stays skinny if
you're fat you get fatter
you exercise as a result when they
looked at that Dad everybody agreed that
they were correct so as a cover article
in August of 2009 eight months later the
myth about exercise it won't make you
lose weight anybody here to raise horses
or work with horses raise your hand okay
if you what do you call when a horse
shoes on the fence cribbing very good
and how do you get rid of cribbing in a
horse you shoot him in the head that'll
stop it but I mean what else can you do
to get a horse to stop cribbing what
yeah you give a trace mineral salt
blocker you give them bone meal or some
minerals and they'll stop within three
to five days they'll stop chewing on the
fence
well those you've never seen cribbing
this is a stall in a barn and a horse
and buggy Amish farm in Switzerland
County Indiana in the southeastern
corner of Indiana and I don't even need
to look at the horse or do tests on them
I just look at the rails and their stall
in the barn I can see that that horse is
merely deficient now it's called
cribbing and animals is called the
munchies in humans now it is socially
unacceptable it's socially unacceptable
for your little kids eat the neighbors
furniture in your visit
and that's where we developed the custom
that's redeveloped the custom of taking
and giving them cookies and drinks they
all have calories in it so we came up
with a program that works every time
obviously you have to take the 90
essential nutrients pride you ate one
healthy start pack for a hundred pounds
of body weight per month and then if
you're a diabetic we'd like you to throw
in and you don't have to be a diabetic
but certainly a diabetic you could also
throw this in if you're not a diabetic
the slender FX weight management system
it has some gluten free water soluble
fiber so you feel satiated it's got a
meal replaced or you can either make it
into a cold shake or an ice cream you
make it water and it has 80 calories and
no sugar and great for diabetics also
has some accelerators here to speed up
the weight loss but the real secret
sauce for weight loss is this one ASAP
put a dropper full of this under your
tongue thirty minutes before each meal
and this replaces the HCG diet how many
heard of the HCG diet okay that requires
injections you got to do this whole
thing with the doctor my prescription
stuff well this is the raw material for
your body to make your own HCG can put
this under your tongue thirty minutes
before each meal and you will lose
weight and keep it off ASAP ASAP as slim
as possible as soon as possible I'll
show you two examples one boy one girl
this is Jerry from Salt Lake City
he'd been this for 12 years at this
point and he had a bread belly you know
he'd been taking the 90 cents inertias
didn't have any health problems but he
had a bread belly how many ever heard of
a beer belly raise your hand okay sure
well good German knows that beer is
liquid bread every German knows that
beer is liquid bread why because the
ingredients in beer and the ingredients
are better exactly the same the only
difference between bread and beer is one
is fermented and the other one's baked
the same ingredients
same ingredients only bakers and
fermentation is just difference in
preparations the same stuff so it
shouldn't be too hard for you to
understand how somebody who eats bread
can get a bread belly just
people who drink beer get a beer belly
all right so all we added to his program
he's been he just took two healthy start
packs and he drank the rebound because
he's a little bit of a farmer his wife
Judy loved to make bread he had bread
for breakfast lunch dinner and bedtime
snack make his wife happy support his
wife's hobby of making bread
organically-grown
multigrain you know the drill so we
added the ASAP 45 days he loses 50
pounds primarily from his belly okay
because this product will preferentially
move your your metabolism to
preferentially burn belly fat and you
can do crunches you do all that kind of
stuff you can lose 50 pounds you'll lose
muscle before you lose belly fat I see a
lot of people shaking their heads yes
right have you ever tried to lose belly
fat it's very difficult but this stuff
will do it I'll show you another one
here you already know this person lit
already had a gal brandy who introduced
me she's five foot two and in this
picture she weighed 158 pounds one third
of her body weight was fat okay I
apologize for this being out of focus
but this came off of her driver's
license with a phone camera very so
she'd been with us for about eight years
at this point we and she'd been using
her products or her husband as a heavy
equipment driver and he like bread so
she made bread for him and what was ever
leftover she needed right rather than
let it go away she ate it and so we put
her on the rebound because she was
drinking two litres of Pepsi today only
five foot two Julie was a Pepsi day and
so we put on rebound instead of the the
Pepsi and then she lost her own
twenty-something pounds and she still
need to lose another thirty so she got
on the ASAP and in a month's time she
got down 206 pounds 158 206
Healthy Start pact rebound and ASAP no
that was I think she got down to this
hundred and six pounds in January of
this year she's still hundred six pounds
you'll keep your weight off as long as
you're taking in the minerals
appropriate for your body weight because
you don't have the munchies anymore
everybody else you can lose weight
there's a million different ways to lose
weight but you always gain it back
because you haven't solved the problem
there'll deficiency you get the picture
okay now I can move on here well so I
should do this one here I forgot Tim's
here well the guys who can help register
tonight Tim he lost forty four and a
half pounds and eight inches and weighs
in just 60 days on the program he's been
with us for a while but the ASAP and
he's been able to keep it off he was
telling me he was hiking up in the
mountains and because he lost that 45
pounds he did pretty good okay how many
ever heard of Al's heart disease raise
your hand okay Allister disease is a
physician cause disease elsewhere
disease is a physician cause disease
didn't exist 40 years ago even by
another name today it's the number four
cause of death and Americans over the
age of 65
so it goes from zero four years ago now
it's the number four cause of death as
caused by physicians I'll tell you how
what is Allister disease well Alison
Rosie's is it going away the mile and is
the white mare of the brain how many
heard a myelin well see younger people
should know violence that white matter
the brain insulation material when it
goes away the naked nerve fibers all
tangled up for the diagnostic features
announcer MERS these at autopsy you get
these nerve tanks you probably read
about nerve tangles and this is caused
by the myelin going away well Milan
makes up 75 percent of your brain weight
the gray matter your brain the thinking
part the memory part the problem-solving
part your brain
makes up 2 percent of your brain weight
it's like 2 millimeters of this little
covering or the white matter the white
matter makes up 75 percent of your brain
weight well
this myelin is white matter of the brain
that makes up 75 percent of the brain
weight is a hundred percent cholesterol
so you go on a close very strict diet
you take cholesterol-lowering drugs BAM
you have Alzheimers disease cuz you
can't maintain the white matter your
brain anymore you given up all the raw
matures you're taking drugs to drive
your cholesterol down because doctors
said it would make you live longer let's
have a look Alzheimers tidal wave feared
why is that there's 80 million baby
boomers come along they'll listen to
doctors lower their cholesterol with
diet and drugs this came out in 2009
Alzheimers and relentless Alberta Canada
reminds me of that obesity chart finally
doctor destruction is going this way why
because numbers look particularly grim
for baby boomers who follow the doctor's
instructions exercise drink plenty of
water don't eat fat need plenty of whole
grains oh yeah use oils instead of lard
and dairy and eggs like George Francis
oh we're gonna see a lot of this kind of
stuff now a mother and son share the
bonds of love Al's her disease and the
same doctor who lured their cholesterol
now any Mormons in here tonight any
Mormons any Mormons I'm disappointed no
Mormons okay any seventh-day adventists
any okay the reason why I'm asking that
question is 2004 Johns Hopkins School of
Medicine came out with a wonderful study
on Al's heart disease they went to Cache
County Utah and they chose Cache County
I mean you could get 5,000 people for a
study in Baltimore Maryland right so why
did they go all the way out to cash
County Utah
let's because in Cache County each other
extremely religious Mormons almost like
Arthur Noxon Jewish people when it comes
to
they actually have a book called the
words of wisdom which supplements the
Book of Mormon and it tells me what to
eat what not to eat right and so all of
these people in Cache County Utah the
oldest living people in America they
live the eighty seven seven day
Adventists would be eighty five the
Mormons as a group would be eighty five
but the the Mormons in Cache County Utah
will live to be eighty seven they're all
farmers very religious farmers with the
background from Scotland they all come
just older culture it comes from
Scotland so culture the same same
genetic pool same diet the same
profession live in the same county same
everything same time it's really a great
study I mean it's like laboratory rats
right it's just perfect and what they do
is take five thousand these people over
the age of sixty five they gave half of
them a couple of vitamins the other half
they gave a sugar pills a blind setter
nobody knew who was getting one well the
end of the study those getting the
vitamins reduce their risk of alessandra
disease by seventy percent those getting
the sugar pill increase their
Alzheimer's disease risk by seventy
eight percent but he had remember the
the diet was the basic thing okay
now in the Ale industry we give him the
perfect diet very similar to the Mormon
diet and the Jewish diet the seventh-day
Adventist diet but we also add all 90
essential nutrients we eliminate
alzheimers disease and animals by 100
percent
so now you know alzheimers disease is
not genetic there's no way could be
genetic if you can reduce the risk of a
lasar disease by seventy-eight
percentages might take a couple of
vitamins and a particular diet it's not
genetic in any way shape or form again
doctors are wrong because their
knowledge is very constricted they have
a very narrow range of training they
know little or nothing
every time they utter the word nutrition
or give you a nutritional advice they
should be put in jail as a felon that
would stop them from killing people they
say the first two letters of the word
nutrition they should be put in jail
you're a jail put the cuffs on him now
give you an example this is ray McGregor
from Charlotte North Carolina and his
sister who's one of our associates one
of our distributors three years ago
called me and said her brother eight
years earlier had been diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease very severe very
rapidly advancing the doctors tried all
these drugs they say it can help a
dementia no help so she took him over
the eight year period before she called
me to three neurological clinics and
then she took him to the medical school
two weeks before she called me and went
to the department or ology at the
medical school there in North Carolina
and said look I want the I'm demanding
that the head of the department
neurology examine my brother which he
did look this guy he said he's curled up
on the floor he's being fed through a
g-tube there's nothing we do drives one
guy the love is not gonna help him
money's not going to help me put him in
a hospice if you're gonna do that put
him the one that I own right well he
didn't say that but I just threw that it
put him in a house is what he said so
she calls me so there's four different
dimensions there's vaster dementia which
used to be called senile dementia
there's nothing wrong with your brain
when you have seen out dementia of a
sternum it it's actually a plugging of
the arteries in your brain just like you
get coronary arteries it plug they can
plug here can plug there right
and then there's Korsakoff syndrome
which is a deficiency of a single
vitamin was discovered three hundred
years ago set in the Year 1712 by a
Japanese naval surgeon and then there's
wernicke korsakoff's which of course
cough syndrome that deficiency of that
vitamin and MS multiple sclerosis mixed
in together and then there's al Center
disease so here's what I told her to do
I said look we're gonna treat him for
all four and I do this literally a
thousand times a year it always works
out so we're gonna try this in your
brother too
we gave him two healthy start packs he
weighed 185 pounds we gave him two
healthy start packs got him off all the
bad stuff no fried foods no oils was
difficult because what are they feeding
him through his g-tube ensure which is
all carnival it's easy to get through
the tube miss you count the calories and
that's why they made it out of carnival
they don't consider what it does for the
patient and what it does to the patient
right ensures worse I wouldn't give in
sure to a communist okay bad stuff so to
healthy start packs for month none of
the bad stuff now for The Bachelor
dementia I threw in three twice a day of
the ultimate daily tabs which are
designed to get blood flow through
plugged arteries and support healthy
blood pressure and so on then for the
Korsakoff syndrome I gave them three D
stress capsules twice is two bottles a
month it has the vitamins in it that are
missing when you have coarse coma
syndrome and then for wernicke
korsakoff's I added selenium to it three
of those twice a day as two bottles a
month to deal with the lesions of the MS
which you can get rid of those and ms
goes away and then for the alton disease
I threw in 12 eggs a day to rebuild the
myelin of the brain because the
cholesterol has gone on his brain so I
gotta get ramped up his cholesterol game
12 eggs a day and three of our what we
call smart FX three times a day that's
three bottles a month ultimate daily
tablets and then last one is smart FX
three of those you're like get smart
okay three of those three times a day at
three bottles a month and that's the raw
materials for your brain to make the
neurotransmitters for memory duh so she
calls me in two weeks I'm gonna give you
an exact quote of what she called me
actually was a week when we give you the
exact quote she calls me on the radio so
I have
disk yeah I'm even gonna quote the
utterances she made she calls me
intuition she says he's cured he's cured
now ray and his wife love me because he
was that close to death put him in a
hospice he'd been dead in two weeks okay
now he didn't have Alzheimers disease
like all those doctors said he had
Korsakoff syndrome which is curable in
two weeks by giving him the vitamin
remember I hedge my bet and I'd feed him
for all four it paid off for Ray I do
this a thousand times a year maybe more
than that and I don't even know it but
those are the ones I know about I do
have to tell you that sugar aggravates
the deficiency of that vitamin sugar
aggravates the deficiencies in vitamins
so I thought this is kind of profound
and this came out in February of 2012
this year high calories from sugar
linked to mild memory loss and elderly
here deficient at bottom you're taking
lots of sugar juices and fruit and
molasses and honey and agave syrup and
soft drinks and desserts and candy bars
guess what
you're gonna get dementia but it's not a
disease it's this Korsakoff syndrome or
Wernicke Korsakoff syndrome sugar and
oil is the worst possible thing you give
to anybody the brain problem
particularly the elderly right the same
formula works also on part disease MS
multiple sclerosis as I already
mentioned and also Lou Gehrig's disease
ALS thousands of these people a year
were able to reverse from there's a
JUnit take 60 90 days I'm very famous in
Western Canada for this or some very
wealthy guys had parked disease and we
went back there were three months after
we got him go there wise worried I mean
they made him stick to the thing they
ground up everything put Turkey basing
syringe to their g-tubes went back from
three months one of them was
he comes all our meetings and he's very
wealthy guy and I had put all his
employees on our program and his name is
David Dietrich's he had all these
patents for quick release and quick
coupling tractor equipment and he comes
up to me says hi doc I really don't
remember you but but you're the guy who
saved me I'm the one that used to have
parking season and he was a vegetable
line for him and now he's perfectly
healthy in just three months and he'd
been getting worse and worse worse for
12 years you're very dangerous now
because now you know okay arthritis
90% of all arthritis is a simple mineral
deficient disease only 2% of arthritis
is rheumatoid arthritis caused by an
infection that's curable in two weeks
you can cure which are thrives in two
weeks with it with antibiotics we've
known that for seventy years I see
there's no longer corn Dodgers are
curious so how do they treat you and
let's see here they give you presents on
cortisone they give you a methotrexate
they give you gold shots they do joint
replacements so $150,000
why should they take $300 in office
calls see now you become very dangerous
now but close now you know the truth 85
percent of the people who rheumatoid
arthritis also have bone to bone
arthritis and so you still even with
rheumatoid arthritis even though it's an
infection when it's advanced they're all
knurled up even people like that within
a year we can get him playing concert
piano we've done it hundreds of times
you know they're all in our hold up no
surgeries no joint images just within a
year they've repaired it's an amazing
thing okay give him a healthy bone and
joint pack you throw in what we call the
the killer biotic kind of like
Geraldine's boyfriend killer mm-hm so we
may recognize this fella Andy Young
it'll civil rights movement this is 1991
I was a little porkier back then she had
about 60 pounds since then but Andy was
scheduled to get a double knee
replacement cuz he had bone to bone
arthritis 1991 athletes told him about
me so he called me and said can you help
me
he canceled his Delanie replacement
surgeries and that was 21 years ago it's
never had to have any joint surgery and
he's perfectly healthy now in his 80s he
can outrun an 18 year old and swims 5
miles a day came in on my program for 21
years the coming up epidemic for the
thricewise are coming epidemic of
arthritis s because there's 80 million
baby boomers all of this and the
doctor's exercise is good for you drink
plenty of water do not take any vitamins
minerals you can overdose now do you
think they did that just because they
were stupid because they were protecting
their trophy wife's lifestyle hmm this
came out September 2000 2012 20 sorry
knee surgeries put a strain on cost why
is that because there's 80 million baby
boomers come along and they all want
knee surgeries because the doctors and
insurance pay for it why would I want to
pay $4 a day to rebuild my knee when
insurance pays for surgery because when
you do surgery on your right knee what
does that do for the other 71 joints
your body nothing
you take the healthy bone and joint pack
and support some promotes maintenance
repair of all of them well I better ask
my doctor I get that a lot I better ask
my doctor you better hurry he's 75 years
and 11 and a half months old he's only
got two weeks left
do not take those drugs miss phosphates
pazzo Max and boniva
they only reduce the rate of loss of
brittle old bone they do not build new
bone as doctors told you that's why it's
now 1 800 bad drug Harvard Medical
School New England Journal of Medicine
ten years ago 2002 no internal medicine
they did a meta study on 300,000 people
that had joint replacement surgeries
knees hips shoulders
they just reporters just she's near
surgery because everybody knows about
knees right knee surgery aka all joint
surgeries for arthritis are worthless
that's Harvard Medical School in the New
England Journal of Medicine ten years
ago but you go to any orthopedic surgeon
say oh I've got boned a bonus rise Mo's
knees and all these other doctors want
to do joint replacement well I'll do a
better job and give you a 10% discount
do any of them say hey let's try the
healthy bone and joint pact for 90 days
here and then we'll decide about surgery
no no no so what I want you to do is is
give young jibbety give me 90 days do
the healthy bone and joint pay if you
have any joint problems I have to tell
you I'm 73 years old I've been doing
this for 64 years I started when I was
nine I started taking nothing healthy
bone and joint pact the way it is but
the 90 essential nutrients twice a day
she says nine years old read the book
dead dogs a lie tells you the story how
I figured it out when I was nine I
figured that I had a little help right
no nine year olds gonna figure it out
then so a most had some help but think
about it I haven't been sick one day in
64 years people know me for a long time
I've never been sick in 64 days I've
never been on a prescription medication
never I can still in another eight hours
a lecture on one foot if I can balance
myself here I mean not many 73 year old
guys who then do that because they have
arthritis and pain and their feet and
their backs knowledge Costa and so it
has nothing to do with age it has to do
with everything you're giving your body
all the raw materials it needs to
maintain itself you put all in your car
you change the oil every 3,000 miles
like the maintenance book says that car
will last 300,000 miles you don't change
the oil you don't replace it as it's
burning up
you might only go 50,000 miles right so
give me 90 days if I fail you can always
get the surgery if you go get the
surgery first you can't always get unser
gee not in fact an unparallel eyes on
dead four years later the same group of
doctors same database looked at back
surgery low back pain sciatica restless
leg syndrome peripheral neuropathies
numbers burning tingling in your neck
and feet and hands and so forth
degenerative disc disease surgery
unnecessary for sciatica and low back
pain low back problems give me 90 days
if I fail you with a healthy bone and
joint pack you could always right you
can always go get the surgery but you
don't want to go get surgery first
because of all the terrible things that
they do to patients for the back surgery
that's the worst I see people all the
time they're all oh yeah they put two
rods in my back 14 years ago and I'm
doing fine now everything's good yeah
give me 90 days okay diabetes is a
simple mineral deficient disease is not
genetic in any way shape or form we've
known that for 70 years it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease but again
doctors are not obligated to cure you
when there's a cure available there are
protected monopolies they can do what
they want and as long as you agree to it
everybody's happy
wise are gonna be a diabetes epidemic
eighty million baby boomers come home
exercise sweat out your nutrients drink
plenty of water don't take by tomatoes
you can overdose I must hear that a
thousand times a day if I hear at once I
know who to strangle first the patient
or the doctor and here's why you'll be
burying your children Wall Street
Journal April of this year no easy cure
for diabetic children now we're not
talking about type 1 this is type 2 it
used to be called adult onset type 2
diabetes because it only occurred in
people over the age of 50 well that was
a long time ago in 1963 people under the
age of 5 never got type 2
look following the doctors and
governments drugs eatable grains don't
eat fat you know plenty of exercise
don't supplement look what him if the
doctors were right in the government is
right the chart should look like that
again following the instructions and
what they say this is what you're
getting and so the kids are dying
younger and younger and younger just
from type 2 diabetes when nobody should
get it's a simple mineral deficiency
high blood sugar is not the disease high
blood sugar is just a symptom is he just
like elevated blood cholesterol is a
symptom of type 2 diabetes it has
nothing to do with the cause of the
disease how about sugar
do not get statin drugs because they
increase your risk of diabetes type 2
diabetes by 50% and this came out what
[Music]
2012 right just like the other one I
showed you I don't get all the easy ones
when I get people with diabetes I
usually get them with complications
here's some gangrene of the foot
I see gangrene and legs all the way up
to the groin and a good endocrinologist
he loves this I mean the toes are
crystallizing there's not much healthy
flesh left so look at the foot off right
there at the arch if it goes up too late
but cut the leg off in the middle of the
thigh up at the groin well with our
program usually takes 2 to 14 days to
wean a monster medication now there an X
I bet akin 2 to 14 days it happens like
all the time the longest it ever takes
is 3060 days but I'd say 80% of them or
2 to 14 days so they do exactly as I say
they'll we know their medication because
we're giving them the mineral that's
missing but what about the complications
what about blindness what about heart
disease what about gangrene will it just
all goes away usually 30 to 60 days we
do have to have one thing for January is
called the ultimate daily tablets just
like for vascular dementia in coronary
artery disease for this would also add
in addition to the healthy blood sugar
pack which is the healthy starter pack
in the sweeties appropriate for body
weight if they have complications of the
heart our eyes or brain or complications
of the gangrene given
daily at the circulation going here's
another one the shows they don't know
anything
diabetes cases made doubled by 2050 and
perhaps even triple now what does it
tell you about their level of knowledge
when it comes to the cause of these they
don't nothing all they did was tracking
numbers and treating the same way over
and over and over
I remember Albert Einstein he here's a
Nobel Prize winner one of my favorites
and he said many global things are
unimpeachable my favorite is insanity is
doing the same thing over and over
expecting a different result he's the
one that came up with that what a
beautiful global statement right and
this just shows how stupid and insane
they are so again the healthy blood
sugar pact if they have complications
whatever is necessary to deal with the
complications usually within 2 to 14
days or an ex diabetic so it's not
cholesterol the plugs the arteries what
is it it's inflammation causes the arms
by eating fried foods and eating oils
and processed meats with nitrates and I
try it so all the things are turn into
trans fatty acids even a room
temperature you go to a restaurant well
we're very careful as we want salad but
we want to dry we don't want any
dressing on it you know when I go to a
restaurant I have all my eggs poached at
home I'll soft scramble my eggs and
butter because I know I'm using butter
if I ask the cook in the inter and I hop
or a Denny's to scramble my eggs and
butter you know they're gonna do they're
using honey it tastes like butter
because it's cheaper and they think
they're doing me a favor because it's
you know it's an oil or margin I want to
be like George Francis Libyan hundred
twelve at least okay
the secret killer is not cholesterol
have you heard of Saturday kneading post
see young people don't even know it I
thought it was a dead magazine Ted I
even know it still existed this is a May
June 2012 issue cover article fill pill
shocker cholesterol meds may be useless
they left out two words they should have
said cholesterol meds may be useless and
dangerous articles title was a
cholesterol conundrum one of the doctors
interviewed for the information that
article said everything you've heard
about cholesterol and heart disease are
wrong who told everybody that
factors and then a summary of speaking
to twelve different doctors these
authors of this article spoke to twelve
different doctors who were primarily
heads of the department's of Cardiology
at Medical School said this is a summary
cholesterol levels are actually a fairly
weak predictor who will have a heart
attack what what now this is just the
obvious what they said even two weeks
before this article came out now I said
this in 71 they thought it was an idiot
now they're saying what I said 41 years
earlier okay cholesterol levels are
actually a fairly weak predictor who
will have a heart attack because that's
true cholesterol has nothing to do with
a heart attack you saw this one earlier
now this will mean something to you good
cholesterol not so beneficial higher HDL
high density lipoproteins a good
cholesterol levels don't reduce heart
attack lower your cholesterol of any
kind good or bad doesn't reduce heart
attacks does not cause it he spent a
trillion dollars a year for 50 years for
nothing he spent all that money and all
that energy and all that consideration
eating stupidly
and you're ranked 92nd the world in
healthfulness 60th longevity that's what
you got for following the doctor's
instructions all these illiterate people
out there doing just the opposite
doctors say just cause are illiterate
Liberty hundred twelve pediatricians
went in on the largesse now they want to
get the kickbacks suits that are gonna
start giving eight-year-olds statin
drugs to lower their cholesterol because
they think if we lower the cholesterol
levels and kids eight years old will
prevent heart disease in adults and what
you're gonna say is no do not let them
give your kids cholesterol-lowering
drugs because they will die before
they're 20 and you will be standing a
gravesite bearing your children the last
thing we share with you is my favorite
article and cholesterol we'll talk about
high blood pressure I'll be done this is
the last one of closer always my
favorite article on cholesterol normal
cholesterol an 88 year old man was
calling Frank who eats 25 eggs a day
published in the New England Journal
meza this is not a big study this is a
case report but it's very valuable this
guy Frank goes in 88 years old for his
annual physical and doctor kerned who's
a clinical doctor in the outpatient
clinic at Harvard
school she teaches you know young
doctors how to be doctors and that's
scary
and dr. Curran comes to Franken says
look you're pretty good shape for 88
years old man we couldn't find anything
wrong with you I'm gonna reward you I'm
gonna give you a prescription of Viagra
so Frank stands up kind of lifts up his
belt you know and throws his shoulders
bang says I'm pretty good in that area I
don't need no viagra says actually
really what do you do you know what do
you do to be good neder he says well I
eat 25 eggs a day the doctor said what
the doctors having a heart attack what
25 eggs a day so doctor runs it back in
the lab and he reruns in himself he
couldn't believe the numbers so he Ken's
banks as well your blood cholesterol is
190 without medication and why do you
meet 25 eggs a day says well beyond that
makes me more studly know what you think
about it how many ever heard of estrogen
progesterone okay that's to see roid
hormones have you heard of adrenal
hormones okay that's another steroid
form how many heard testosterone
it's another steroid hormones those four
hormones are steroid hormones and
they're 95 percent by weight cholesterol
so you go on a cholesterol restricted
diet you take cholesterol-lowering drugs
ain't nobody home anymore okay you have
a rectal dysfunction that's why they
have so many ads on TV after 10 o'clock
at night there's Bob selling insight
and the one I really love is cialis you
know there's couple on the beach and the
bathtubs now they're genetic line who's
gonna die out there very stupid you got
to be in the same bathtub before there's
the right moment
I mean two slabs of cast-iron him in
between his hate nothing gonna happen no
matter how good your erection is right
now
so heat six to eight eggs a day and you
know Ted and his wife Nasim and Brandi
they always eat with me a lot in the
road when I go to these places I'll have
a big steak if it's breakfast time I'll
have four eggs that are poached with a
big hamburger patty or a breakfast steak
and you can see all the people in the
place are eating their organic
multigrain waffles looking at me and
they don't even know they're dead men
walking so you take your 90 essential
nutrients we actually have an
aphrodisiac called Drive it's a little
capsule and and the main ingredient is
an urban it's an Asian herb called horny
goat weed
it's a great little herb called Drive we
add that to our a couple of other things
a lot of fun okay the stealth killer
high blood pressure is a simple mineral
deficiency how it pressure is not
genetic in any way shape or form even in
the black community it's not genetic
millions don't manage blood pressure
well that's because they're treating
symptoms or they're not dealing with the
cause causes and mineral deficiency salt
has nothing to do with high blood
pressure what's the first thing a good
farmer Rancher puts out for his
livestock in the pasture a salt block or
Salt Lick right there's nobody on that
pasture telling a cow she's limited in
one lick a day is there I refuse to
believe my human patients are dumber
than a cow holy also if you're bibbing
biblically orientated it's kind of fun
God said go forth and miss all to the
earth right I mean it's in the Bible and
God is forever now doctors say restrict
salt natal it would be 56 I'm going with
God
big study Oh houston we have a problem
here low sodium intake could be riskier
that's because sodium is an essential
nutrient you cannot have nerve impulses
without sodium you can't move water
around you're buying about sodium you
can't make stomach acid without chloride
chloride and sodium are probably the
most common of all the mineral cofactors
necessary for enzymes and genes to work
well houston we have a problem
now while this study was designed to
deal with high blood pressure in the
black community because doctors
convinced the black community that have
a pressure is genetic in them this also
is true for heat whites and blacks and
yellows and reds and oranges and
everybody right what they do is go from
Loyola University in Chicago and our
University in London
to Nigeria they want to go up in the
mountains of Nigeria and find some
tribal guys that had normal blood
pressure take their blood samples and
make a vaccine come back genetically
engineered thing injected and every
black man woman and child and get rid of
pellet pressure that way well they get
out to Nigeria from from Oxford
University and Loyola University and
they find out that only 7% of the people
living in the tribal areas of Nigeria
have high blood pressure 93% of normal
that freaked him out to go back to
London they go back to Chicago they
started doing DNA tests looking for gene
pools of people whose ancestors had
originated from West Africa during the
slave trading days of the 1600s 1700s
they found lots of them they started
just simply screening by doing blood
pressures they found out that the people
of the same genetic pool as from West
Africa as the West Africans a 33% high
would pressure so you know me it's not
genetic because your position on earth
doesn't dictate our change how a genetic
disease will manifest itself you have
genetic disease here you know and
Minneapolis you're going to have it in
London you're gonna have it in Cape Town
South Africa you're gonna have an
Auckland New Zealand doesn't matter
where your honor the jank is eating me
the same so when there's a five times
difference here between you and where
you live you know it's not genetic and
Malayan like that so they gathered up
more more blood samples from Nigeria
more blood samples from all over the
world from people who had
from Nigeria their ancestors during the
slave trading days and they got in the
geneticist and they got in the
cardiologist and a blood pressure people
and all this stuff and they studied for
six years and in 2005 January 2005 they
came out with the final results of the
study
remember doctors once you believe that
its genetic this is published in the
British Medical Journal which is their
version of the journal the american
michael socha round the world and here's
what they said hold on to your hands
high blood pressure and blacks not
genetic help fish and whites not genetic
high blood pressure and yellows not
genetic high blood pressure and Red's
not you think it's not genetic anybody
it says simple mineral deficient disease
now and how many in this room
particularly the black individual in
this room how many of you had your
doctor send you an email
in 2005 sing praise God we just learned
that high low pressure in blacks not
genetic he just take the healthy start
packing the ultimate daily tablets blood
pressure goes away in a couple weeks
hallelujah anybody get that I speak to
black churches all the time they've
never heard of that you know how many
black men have died in the last seven
years because they didn't get the
information or 100,000 from a high blood
pressure stroke somebody needs to go to
jail mm-hmm
but they won't because they're protected
monopoly so how do we deal with this we
tell people ourselves we share this
information and get people to do things
for themselves they won't need doctors
and here comes the fun part in August of
2003 in the journal the American Medical
Association of all things JAMA the
Journal American Medical Association in
August 2003 there was a big article in
there about an herb that lowers blood
pressure has flavanols and it's called
dark chocolate not milk chocolate not
Hershey's bars but dark chocolate has a
substance and it called flavanols which
lowers blood pressure now doesn't solve
the problem of the mineral deficiency
but a lack like a plant medicine or
plant medicines it'll lower your blood
pressure so you don't have a stroke
until you you're taking enough minerals
for you to eliminate it permanently
right but I just keep taking it because
I like it
my blood pressure I'm 73 years old my
blood pressure is 121 over 71 my blood
my pulse is 43 a does spike when I get
any real spike up is 45 when I get angry
when I was wrestling for the University
of Missouri my resting pulse for 38 and
the doctors were always freaking out but
I could always outrun them out with them
and all of a sudden the other right
and in addition dark chocolate has
another substances of fun substance
called PE a s phenol F la means how many
of you heard of phenol if Allah means
okay this is the reason why we give
chocolate on Valentine's Day because the
phenol f Lemmy's now the Spanish they
didn't know the name of the chemical but
they knew there was something special
about dark chocolate so in 1523 they
took out to Europe and started giving it
away on Valentine's Day is the whole
purpose of dark shot was to seduce the
woman the dark chocolate
PGA's female if allah means are the love
chemical they're an aphrodisiac right
it's really great stuff it's got to be
dark chocolate so in that year 2003 we
came out with a product called cocoa
gemma tea and cocoa gemma tea has
flavanols it will lower your blood
pressure but it's also loaded with PJs
it always works guys
so when Valentine's comes up and it's
coming up in a couple of months don't
give chocolates give cocoa jibbety and
reap the awards reap the rewards it okay
if you like pieces of chocolate rather
than the liquid I like the liquid I add
it to my coffee we own a coffee coming
called Java fit and made us
publicly-traded one of the things we do
if you I personally I don't take
anything from the company even though I
started to coming out and take anything
from it
I give it all back to you guys you know
if you help other people the more people
you help the bigger your check gets this
gets good okay
here we triple treat chocolate
a triple treat chocolate trouble treat
chocolate why is it called triple treat
because the lowers blood pressure it has
probiotics in it which gives you good
digestive stuff and gives you the best
sex like you ever had
triple treat right because it has
flavanols in it to lower blood pressure
but also has PTAs in it phenyl methyl
means good stuff now two of these two of
these chocolates gives you 33,000
antioxidant points 33,000 orange points
which is right and a half way mark
between 20,000 50,000 days top 20
longevity people lower blood pressure
33,000 org points and PTAs i mean how
good does that get and we also have
another one called triple truffle in
addition it has 500 milligrams of usable
calcium per piece which is the size of a
pad of butter and a thousand
international about Amanda tree so if
you take three of those you're getting
1500 milligrams of usual calcium and
three thousand international units of
vitamin d3 which is a minimum daily
requirement for vitamin d3 no this is
not standalone product obviously you add
that to the 90 essential nutrients and
whatever else you got going so that's
sort of and I could go on with you know
894 other disease we don't have time for
that but you can read the book dead
doctors alive let's play doctor and so
on which I go through those diseases
with you and tell you what to do for and
so what I'm gonna do now is turn this
over to brandy into Seema and Ted and
they're going to give you some
information and you can flip on the
lights now well the lights can go up and
I will then answer questions for you for
about I don't know half hour 45 minutes
and we'll have a lot of fun and save a
lot of people okay thank you very much
[Applause]
you